two hello
everybody is divine yeah this is my
Enrique and glaces remix thank you
everybody for being here all I
need is to look in your eyes do have you
caught up uh by the way I'm with SOS
today
heish hell yeah baby
yeah he's poining me today here a fan
favorite since the last appearance we
had so much fun great to be back welcome
back and thank you and it's nice to have
you back saos just put out a new special
on Netflix fat Rascal which I watched
was very oh yeah thanks dude
congratulations thank you
brother and I actually I want to give it
up to you a little bit here okay I want
to start off by saying it's the first
standup routine I've seen in years M
decades decades that didn't have a trans
joke or a we just can't comedians can't
tell jokes no more right right right
yeah I
think totally devoid devoid of that yes
um I know it's funny because I do have a
trans joke but I literally kept it out
like uh and it's very transphobic no no
no no no I'm kidding I'm no no no well
it's basically I just kept it out
because I was like for that exact reason
cuz I was like why does it feel like
even though it's a good joke and it was
like and it probably we could have
released it as a clip and it probably
would have done well but I was just like
why does everyone feel the need to weigh
in I cut some other and also it's not
done yet fully I also cut some family
stuff CU I felt like let me work harder
on it and this one is all what I like to
say about this special it's like it's
like a special about a man who's losing
to all of his vices that's basically
what it is I'm being destroyed it's a
year of destroying my life is that what
is that an accurate representation last
year oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah but hey
[__] it last time we we met we were on a
similar weight loss the desires we went
yeah we had a little little fork in the
road for both of
us yeah your ass looking weak these days
and I'm looking
healthy yeah yeah yeah no basically I
sacrificed my body to my career and it
worked the special's [__] good so but
hold on you're saying nobody's loving
those unless you're a fat Rascal no no
I'm just saying I was on the road every
weekend you didn't have time I didn't
have time and that's you know so what
are we doing on the road that's
destroying our body travel bad bad you
know bad meals dude whatever the [__]
open at 1:00 a.m. after the show nothing
good nothing good I recently I recently
started like trying to you know get a
smoothie I basically was like let me
survive the last month I was like damn I
don't want to die before the special
comes out so I started Uber eing
[__] you know but I had to get it's kind
of like my health is kind of like I'm a
procrastinator even in my health it's
like when I get so fat I get worried I'm
like all right some salads now so I mean
are you currently at your Peak height or
have you been larger before I think I've
been the only thing that Rivals this is
when I went to college and I was set
loose in the uh in the unlimited meal
plan dining hall 18-year-old Meck you
know what I mean no no poverty me I had
none of my parents my my mom not yelling
me for eating all the Lucky Charms in
one sitting you know I could just keep
that weird little dial turn you know
they those [__] up cereal dispensers I
was [__] those I was just having
Captain Crunch with soft serve ice cream
and a little milk for dessert every meal
like we're talking for breakfast for
lunch I was [__] it up dude yeah I
got fat as [__] um but yeah this was
this is pretty much the the height of it
but you know what are you going to do I
mean it's all hey there you know it's
it's all easy from here yeah yeah yeah
yeah absolutely what they say is it's
easier to lose weight the older you get
that's what everyone says yeah it's it's
a wellknown phenomen you want to get
fatter as as you get older that's what
what most doctors say although in truth
I F find the bigger that I've got it's
easier to lose a bunch of weight fast
yeah and the truth is like I was at 250
at my biggest M and now I'm would kill
to be 250 by the way would be so sick
you pushing can I ask it's tough I I
stopped weighing myself that's you know
when you get there oh so you you have an
acad 250 I was yeah 250 was the last
time you was the last known yeah I see
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah it was the
last known seismic measurement right
right right right right yeah I hit I hit
310 and I was like I don't need any more
notes are you at 310 yeah I'm a I'm a
dense boy I'm you know what I mean
little suf you know what those are I
don't know it's a jelly fil donut and
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah some and some
real viscous jelly too it ain't watery
no no no no so
um but it's all good I think I might get
Zed up do it why not I mean like like
just do it yeah whatever it takes it
hasn't killed anyone yet right I don't
think so no no from what I understand it
seems K still alive well let me ask you
this what's safer taking a medicine that
you lose weight on or just weighing 300
lb I don't know know you know that's a
good question I mean how [__] up is
the medicine that's the question um plus
I would love to do something fun with
the all the extra skin oh maybe make a
little maybe make a little uh football
with all do you think you'd have
probably probably a little bit I got a
nice like I said I'm dense yeah I don't
have fluffy fat this [__] is getting
pushed to the Limit yeah you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah have you got so
okay well good luck we we want it we
want a skinny rle next year skinny r
never be skinny oh Jack Ras Jack the
Jack Rascal that's not bad the Jack
rasal yeah zemp [__] testosterone I'm
going all the way I'm combo [__] I'm
going to do [__] steroids and let's
[__] go dude it's a new combo we're
coming as fat boys are coming that
sounds [__] awesome actually I would
love to just disappear imagine if the
next time you saw me yeah that'd be a
little just X Factor yeah not ater all
meth oh straight meth from a craft
straight Crystal
Crystal bro we're coming and you're
never going to know what we're doing
next that boy keep guessing yes so um
but anyway I did want to tip the beanie
in a sense because I felt like for a
long time
comedy I think comedy's in trouble and
and I'll tell you why okay and I think
that you're one of the good guys thanks
man yeah thank you I think it and you
don't you don't have to comment on this
because uh I know uh you're in that
world and comedians there's some kind of
camaraderie between for sure for sure
that being said I do think that Joe
Rogan is the Antichrist and he's ruined
no no Joe's the man I love that
guy is literally the
B no no nice try [__] you're not going
to get me on a clip shaking my head to
this [__] I am saying No in fact
I'm going to say no no no in case you
take the volume out in case you drop my
[__] mic
out he's a tin little demon man's body
he's the man his Club rules by the way
and you want to talk about the guy
opened up a club he's not making money
he's literally running a socialist
comedy club I'm not even kidding you
doesn't need money but that's what I'm
saying how many rich people do you know
who the thing they love that man loves
standup right and he might have
different philosophy than you about it
but he opened up a club paid everybody
through the pandemic and now each spot
you get like $500 so when you're a young
struggling comic you can actually pay
your rent off comedy it's literally the
only place in the world you can do that
say can you name one of the rich people
that does something like this about they
love Yeah Jeffrey EP bought a whole
island sex trafficking and you everybody
up bro exactly that's what I'm saying
rich people have hobes but here's the
thing he is to standup comedy as Epstein
is to child molestation thank you that's
what I'm
saying he's the best in theame yeah he's
the best in the game all right finally
some common grounds I'll tell you why I
think Joe Rogan is the uh second coming
of of the or well not the second coming
because the Antichrist has yet to show
his face and I think well we have seen
it it's the face of a little Joe Rogan
meat eating egg yolk [__] okay the
meat's good you ever you ever had elk I
haven't no don't talk [__] on it unless
you Jo exactly you might see the light
of day kind of funny [__] you so Joe
anyway the reason I say that is because
he's turned into this um gatekeeper SL
kingmaker that like and I I don't think
that you you're one of the very few
comedians that rose up outside of his
influence mhm um and but other a lot of
the other comedians that are super
popular today they're all from Rogan's
sphere of influence and they all do the
same [__] stick that is so hacky
which is like trans people they're are
what's the deal with trans people
they're so weird the trans jokes the
trans jokes are I mean I
I agree that it's like it is hack
because it's just well trodden right
it's like that's my problem you don't
want to keep doing it over and over
again it's not I'm not even getting like
so offended by it it's just so hacky
like move the [__] on but see that that
is true but the thing is it's like most
of anything is bad it's the higher
levels that you have to you know I don't
think everyone in that sphere like Shane
gills is a great comic he's really you
know like and and also I think that's
one of the Avenues you know where you
can like where you can like rise up or
whatever but I also think Rogan just
likes comedy like I Rose you know I had
my own [__] going and he we became
friends because he likes standup and
he's aware of who's good Ralph Barbosa
another really funny comic who didn't
rise from that kind of came through came
through like clips and [__] but Joe had
him on the podcast so it's like there's
people that are in his orbit that you
know just did it themselves but he just
likes to celebrate standups now I agree
with you that the cancel culture [__] I
don't agree with that and I think I
think that like so hacky bro yeah and I
think I also think even if you believe
that my personal philosophy is like I
don't really like comedy that comments
on Comedy you know what I mean it's like
do the thing we've done enough meta
analysis it doesn't have to be meta
analysis just go out and do a joke um
and so that's you know I also think the
best comedy is personal it's not about
[__] culture War [__] it's not about
that kind of stuff um and I do think
that like at the same time though I do
think that you know he is putting
together a club where you can just kind
of like I went I'm I go to that club and
I'll just I like [__] on Tech Bros I
like [__] on crypto I'll [__] I'll I
have Elon jokes at the club you know
Rogan's Club at the Mother Ship it's fun
to do it yeah yeah and I work those
jokes
out at that club and that's good but
none of the other dudes in his sphere of
influence would do anything but [__]
put both nuts of on their mouth I don't
know about that so Ari shafir another
guy who's straight from Rogan's thing
his special Jew is really isn't he like
a cancel isn't his first special like
canceled yeah but that was a long time
ago I AR AR's 85 years old's an old man
but he he just did a special Jew that
was all about like you know his
experiences like you know as an orthodox
he grew up like Orthodox and [__] like
that oh he did that's interesting no
he's a AR is a good dude and a Rogan guy
but but how many how many how many
comedy specials do we need that are
called canceled there was a definitely a
wave there's aund of them yeah yeah no
no I fully I'm not I'm not fighting you
on
that yeah I think the cancel culture
[__] sucks and I think you just just we
should just be funny that's let's just
move on that's the job you know that's
the whole point of the the
job let's remember the primary objective
here what was that tweet of some
comedian who was like it's the
comedian's job to comment on uh social
issues and then somebody was like I
think you forgot to be funny no well
there's a Norm McDonald thing where it's
like comedians are the modern day
philosophers and then Norm's like
shouldn't that be philosophers aren't we
[__] comedians like we're not smart
we're [__] dumb asses my whole point
is never try and make a point I'm not a
point maker I'm a good time have you
know what I mean and that's what I think
comedian should be than shouldn't be
making points I think you know and and
I'm not opposed to points but you
know too many points you get poked
that's true I'm want to be too you don't
want to be a porcupine no absolutely not
and they're cute you know I like
porcupines but not all the time I'm a
little hedgehog um it
was yeah okay but you know I do I do
respect how comedians there's a
camaraderie and everyone uh backs each
other up so I'm not trying to get you to
say anything yeah yeah but we we will
edit that to and send it we'll figure
out a way we'll figure out a
way oh God I'm I'm friends with Whitney
I love Whitney too yes but this was a
pretty this was a funny tweet I guess
what she say she said comedians did not
sign up to be your hero it's our job to
be IR irreverent and dangerous to
question authority and take you through
a spooky mental haunted house that you
can arrive at your own conclusions stay
focused on the people we pay taxes to do
to pay taxes to be moral leaders anyway
Mark Maron said maybe add to be funny to
the list which I yeah it's that's a good
response but that's that's the whole
thing the Jo the job is be funny yeah I
hate the import I mean I I don't that is
a philosophical thing I don't where you
know where some Comics think it's a a
super important thing and I I like that
we're in the lowest rung of show
business I like that this is what
happens if if a famous person gets
caught doing you know sexually
assaulting someone comedy club is like
welcome here you know what I mean we're
like we're the garbage of of of uh is
that right I guess you're right I mean
look at some of the big boy like Chris
De is on tour and [__] I'm saying is
like they don't give a [__] it's the
sewers we're [__] dog [__] just be
funny I think Louis
CK and um and um yeah what's his name
nice drip what I just said his name my
brain has holes in it deia yeah Chris
deia Louis CK and uh who would open for
them who would be I don't know I just
think if you're cancelled you get to do
comedy and like I get the moral but
that's what I'm saying like who gives a
[__] we we're like we're the whole job
is just to be funny it's like the lowest
common denominator I don't want
importance I want people to come out
have a laugh you know what I mean I
don't want the that's it that's the
whole job bless you have a little I sure
do OJ yeah put OJ up let OJ do oh yeah
Roseanne Bar would be a good opener for
them that' be a hell of a Trilogy
Rosanne deah and Lou rosan rosan is
funny hit me with hit me with the [__]
is
white I thought the [__] was
white remember that that's a good clip
that's one of my favorite sound bites of
all time and then she dropped she gave
us a new one I'm so sorry I thought the
[__] was white that was just from a
week ago oh from a week ago brand new
it's a new [__] was white I like that
rosanne's out there pumping out content
still she's not [__] resting on her
Laurels hell no [__] off um I wanted to
say real quick thank you to wait are
these old okay did you guys send me all
right whatever anyway so we have today
last time you were here we had a call in
with our good friend Jimmy Lee I miss
Jimmy and it was so much fun and so we
thought that
today we will um have a call in with
another friend of the show to introduce
you to okay his name is Seaman oh
nice Seaman huh and and
uh well this is one of the most
interesting dudes you're ever going to
meet in your life and I'll tell you how
we met him um I met him
because somebody on I think somebody
posted the subreddit right I think so
yeah so somebody was on YouTube and they
got an
ad this weird [__] guy oh we have it
here I'll just play it for you so so
this ad was being served to people on
YouTube oh that's awesome on our podcast
on our podcast I think so they got this
as an ad before one of our shows aome
take this in I love the look take this
in bro take it in everyone my name is C
also known as New York
[Laughter]
[Music]
City
[__] that's awesome this was a pay go to
be Bros drive.com you'll definitely get
a good return on your investment
obviously hopefully the next year or so
you'll see some return investment we
need some good investors out there who
would really love to invest um some
money would be great or if you can
invest some of your time for an IT
company we'd like you to also act out
the video scenes while you're creating
wonderful hot erotic websites for us um
get back to me my name is cman and my
email is info@ bbros dve.com this is
just a good uh little pitch for our
investors out there it's a fun happy
business to invest in oh yeah um you can
also you'll get percentage of the
business as well whatever you put into
would be great is an he's like yo he
wants a piece of my business want to be
partners how much percentage what do you
think it would cost have you bought in I
haven't bought in but I've promoted him
quite a bit I say you buy in I didn't
know that the I had that opportunity
frankly I
forgot dude so we saw this and we're
like holy [__] who is this guy yeah so
so C man is not a seaman pun no so he's
a I would have guessed for sure it was
about that I don't think it I don't
think in his mind it's a seaman pump you
asked him about that when he first
called in he said no it's not yeah he's
a SE man that's awesome that's awesome
to have a to to allude to a different
type of sexuality and then be all about
your feet I love that yeah yeah he's
he's big and so that's his thing his his
website was like Barefoot brother
Barefoot brother drive.com because his
his main thing is Barefoot on the pedals
in a car yeah yeah you know what I like
about this is like a guy that looks like
this with little you know little
Morpheus glasses very rarely is into his
own feet usually he's he wants to buy
women's I thought he wanted to act as a
middleman it's a little prev next year
special
stop that's R damn I got to work my face
love what was see right what happened in
the face I thought you supposed to lose
weight there first don't know [__] uh
that's a good look uh yeah dude I like
that a guy like this is horny for his
his own feet this guy believes no he
wants other people's feet oh girl didn't
we see another one we should specify
men's feet he's not he's gay and he he
does not care about women's feet at all
gay guys he hates women's Fe brother
Drive okay we've tried to send him and
he can tell yeah you can tell wow always
we tested it once even like a lady that
works construction we tried we made it
look all masculine and [__] he's like no
that's awesome that's [__] that
actually makes me believe that there is
like like objective truth in the
universe that he can always tell a man's
feet versus women there is a constant
truth that's one of the great questions
of our philos philosophical conundrums
yes C man is my North Star true so um we
reached out to him we emailed him and we
were trying for a long time because I
knew I needed to find I needed to talk
with this guy I needed to figure out who
he is and um we did find eventually
connect and we've had this whole love
affair this and and I may say that in
like the
proverbial wrong he you didn't Lube your
arches up for him no no no no but then
there's been all kinds of things like he
kept telling us he had like a monster
[__] like 12 in sick but then we saw one
of his videos and his dick is like
probably I would even vure to say it's
below average really yeah that sucks so
but like he well that's why he became
the Barefoot brother not the bare [__]
brother right you know right a bear
coock he insisted he was that was only a
halfy that we saw though it's not can I
can I show you it please I love that
show me the picture I don't have it I'm
gonna dude I need this I'm gonna ask him
to pull it out when we talk he might
actually [__] he might do yeah yeah
that'd be awesome I'd like to yeah see
it live he won't because his Dick's
probably small so let's see it he might
though might do it let's get him in
let's get him on the horn what the [__]
out brother well he's calling in at uh
two right guys uh two3 well he just sent
me another email he he's hard to Wrangle
yeah he's hard to Wrangle um got a lot
of business ventures yeah he's getting
pedicures all the time probably probably
yeah but he he does this thing where
he'll go we try to get him on the show
try to get on the show and then he'll
message us at like 8:00 p.m. on like
Sunday night night and be like I can
call in
now he does that literally oh this guy's
awesome but he just happened to email me
last week um and uh he actually has a
purpose for calling in this time he said
uh I will discuss uh a funny dildo uh
funny dildo story that's sick sound so
he's got something to share I guess I
would love to get some time with C man I
would love so we're going to definitely
do that um here is by the way some of
the lore that I'll share with you kind
of a look back a retrospective on our
favorite SE man this was him one of his
first calls he starts talking about uh
he had a crazy foot story when from when
he was in Vietnam o okay hold on I got
to back I'm captivated by the story so
you're in
Vietnam so how did you find this
building you're I imagine you're like
wandering Through the Jungle or some
[__] so I was walking around and I
wanted to get a massage because people
said massage are cheap in Vietnam okay
and you're not thinking about feet
you're just looking for a back massage I
just want a full body massage I they say
great cheet I did that so I'm laying on
this this floor and there's these three
guys and all a sudden laying there and
I'm just got I'm getting rubbed and I'm
sitting there going like this and I'm
like so high as standing up and sitting
there
hold wait hold on wait stop stop stop
stop stop hold on hold on so you're
sitting there getting massaged by three
guys three guys yeah three guys and
you're full fully erect at this time I
couldn't help but it just felt good and
then all a sudden I'm kicking because
these I was the guys were like massaging
me and all a sudden my leg and the guy
just jumps on my feet and licks them and
and I was really blown away and I
actually blew aone without touching
myself
God wait hold on you're you're covering
too much ground I I need all the little
details to you man I mean this guy's man
dude he really is this guy [__] rules
yeah I mean yeah and then here's the a
famous Bath House story he told us M um
this is when the whole my towel off just
so I understand that was that his foot
origin story no he was I was just ask
him for some for
some go got from Thea yes yes yes yes
yes but here's another tale from the
sea up and all these creepy old men were
like trying to
Chas well I the men are creepy the old
men like 65 and over I'm not into that I
mean I know that they want to feel loved
in their old age but you know I'm not
old and I don't really want to play with
an old person back that this was like
six seven years ago so I was right you
even young you know in my early 40s but
still I didn't really want so where Z
you're pushing
50 this Asian guy I love his optimism
though yeah he's young at heart he's
young at heart young at Young and [__]
young at [__] it sounds like small dick
but well here you're going to get here's
the big dick propaganda this is where it
begins I can't wait and said to me you
know you have a really nice penis I'm
like well thank you he's like can I play
with it I'm like we're in a bath house
of course you could I mean I'm open free
rain I'll time that the yeah that's he's
like come on what the [__] we're at the
beach there's going to be sand I didn't
know about the bath house phenomenon did
you oh come on that's classic I didn't
know that oh you can't go to a bath
house and not do gay [__] it's one of
that's one of the most standard things
of all time apparently anywhere anytime
any steam room you go to a bath house
and it's just dude's jerking it yeah
which is cool that's the beautiful
that's a part of Gay Culture that I
really admire it's so they have communal
spaces you know they have a commun that
everyone knows you know there's no a
third place yeah I don't I don't think
there's a third space where you get to
get jacked off I don't think there's a
single place like that for like um
hetero people it's too complicated you
know it's too you know people have
different gay guys got you got to love
them they're on the same and I know you
know gay guys aren't a monolith but you
know I'm willing to bet well they are
just one
dick it's beautiful yeah it's beautiful
man they got a nice things going on over
there yeah send that love send the
sucking each other off not even really
talking no yeah won okay so anyway go on
so he's not rude he lets the guy play
with his dick no of course not he's
generous generous
lover to the WF I don't care I like
that's awesome I'm fun I like to have
fun I don't care I got to say man you
dark rooms very different life than I
have you go into these dark you got to
understand when you go in these dark
rooms you know people are touching
people you don't even know what the
person looks like so people you have to
expect that when you go into these sex
places you know what I mean well it's
nice to that he asked though right well
it was really weird because also in
Australia and Australia it's a bit a
different culture like even though
people are not like America though
they're just like they they kind of
don't they kind of does it take for him
to get to the CU he he eventually gets
to this part where I'm captivated just
by I could just listen to
but no no tell me I don't want to how
how long does this go before the part
where the dude asked him to come in a
bag so he can bring it home for
later that's [__] awesome yeah yeah
dude come on he's on the go but anyway
he told us okay hold on so he told us
he's got 12 Ines okay MH and we were all
like dude why don't you do like porn be
like a star something but anyway here we
uncl that's so what do you think about
that oh yeah I'm gonna hold on don't
show anything K Ian I want to make it
larger for you yeah I need to that's now
to me okay well you know what it is this
actually I my money's on his dick's not
as big as he says but there is a world
where if he's a grower and that's a semi
soft penis this is exactly what he said
I don't think it's semi though seen the
video show me send the video how pable
is that no it's seems it seems that he's
like think that's
stiff it looks like it has a little give
to it let's see I'll show you the video
like has a little give to it but I don't
think even in a world where this is just
right soft I don't think he gets a lot
of space to grow I'm just saying it's
not probable it's possible his dick is
big I would my money's not on it but he
didn't when I confronted him on this he
didn't even really fight me on it okay
cuz I I did we had a big
confrontation yeah you're a journalist I
get that you can't be letting [__] you
got to tie your Loose Ends so here is
the video yes always be naked in office
by the way by the way this is the
weirdest porn I've ever [__] seen in
my life two other guys doing gay [__]
this is the these are the videos he
makes hold on watch this it's so weird
the [__] is this
watch can we get isn't it great working
like this every day can we get to his
[__] man I don't need to see these guys
[__] is it's one minute all right man
I'll isn't this like I've never seen
anything like it I don't like this it
almost is like a fat Rascal out on
Netflix right now folks just to Let's
remind why that why I'm here let me just
get you're not here to say gay porn with
me that guys got a nice dick I will say
that's a pretty big hog oh man oh my
goodness
gracious this is weird is it yeah I'm
not liking this so far man okay so so
here's C man's deck wow ah I don't know
one more
time one more time oh interesting so to
me yeah this is like this is a Pruder
film like back is there another caman
dick shot somewhere here yeah here here
see that that's a little bizarre even
that was a weird I'd love I'd love to
zero in on that for hold on this is even
okay here check it out what is that huh
yeah that's interesting that looks
pretty hard see he's he his dick is in
The Uncanny Valley it looks it's shoing
J penis it looks hard and soft at the
same time I don't know but the fact that
it even looks a little hard is is
evidence to me that there's not that
much space to go there's not that much
but again I I could see him being a an
outlier where his dick grows I just all
I'm saying is let's let's do our p's and
q's let's ask him to show us his
hardcock when he calls
in here you go can I show this wait can
I show this what are you it's so
funny describe post it on Twitter that
is good I don't even know what is the
you're trying to show in the stavos head
that's pretty good stuffff yeah okay
good thanks for coming along with me on
that so that's just a little crash
course on see man that's cool I didn't
really need to see the one guy jacking
the other guy off for 10 seconds that I
didn't need to see but you know it's
just a minute law I didn't know where
his dick comes in but I was I did want
you to enjoy just how bizarre it was I
mean that was The Vibes were [__] yeah
The Vibes were absolutely if I didn't
know the context I would I would have no
trouble believing that that was just
full on like sex trade yeah it might it
was they were prisoners I mean it feel
it feels like I don't know that body was
there of their own free will fully I
don't know that they were they I don't
want to I can't go there you don't want
to accuse him of that you don't want C
man's he pays him he puts it on he's a
good man I see I see C man would never
do that we've all you know I've had a
shitty job please don't be arrested C
man and make me eat my words God damn it
but dude here's the thing I you know
I've had a bad job I took money from it
I didn't like it that's kind of what
that felt like you don't want to get
jerked off under [__] fluorescent
lights you know what I mean you don't
want you don't want you want a little
area lamp when you're getting your dick
tugged I think fair enough that's a good
analogy here it is great look by the way
this is for
my Jes Christ that is I'm aali I got a
big dick he want he's aali he's aali how
big are we talking to
man I don't I don't that's something I
really can't discuss you just said you
because you got a big one well it's more
than
[__] I'm
sorry okay okay n or less than 12 so you
oh my good wow he gave himself n and
less than 12 why don't you give us so
you'll give us a range but you won't
give us the exact
measurement because sometimes it's not
always right away that big you don't
want to give us and then he told us he
has this other this meditative uh
practice where he'll he will do like a
No Hands m
with his mind and his dick gets bigger
and bigger and bigger over like 10 hours
that's awesome like a spirit like a Goku
doing a spirit
100% gr like that and I and I'm like I
don't think it works like that man I
don't know though he's he's locked in on
Dick Chi that I don't have access to
yeah yeah he's unblocked I'm listening
oh because in the he of the moment data
no I was told normally it's around a 10
10 and a half when I'm really hard but
when I'm really super turn
horny I could hit 11 cuz I pushed it up
to my belly button once and I was in
pain my was so hard like I don't always
get like that but sometimes I'm really
turned on you know you haven't had it in
a while you're just in the mood
sometimes you're in a really interesting
mood that you really need to be super
sexed up and I pushed myself one day I
swear to God I was in pain like I
thought I had chest pain oh my God
what's happened to me like I was so
turned not enough blood all the blood
went to your [__] I don't know but and
this one guy told me you're probably at
11 I said you got to be
kidding to him if you're that so I mean
listen there's no way right he was
humbled by that man's measurement of his
own [__] 11 is like legendary status
crazy dick size that's like too much but
there's no way that that dick got this
big yeah probably not it's like a full
Subway sandwich is what talking about
yeah yeah yeah you're right cuz they
never give you all 12 inches in Subway
they're usually 11 yeah you're right
you're right I don't think as dick as 11
I think it could get a little more uh I
think get a little more heartier than
what he showed us that's all I'm saying
okay so you're so you're a cman uh
support I want to give him the benefit
of the doubt all right well we'll see
we'll give him a chance to prove himself
today I'd love to chat with him here's
his here's his actually I haven't
checked okay I'm not
watching anyway um so that's that yeah
shout out to C man I can't wait to see
it in the
meantime
um I wanted to update you on our mutual
friend M Jimmy Lee Jimmy James so we had
steo on our show on Monday great dude
love steo love him yeah great guy he's
the man really a good guy you know yeah
and some of the [__] coolest [__] of
all time I mean true like a legend
that's true and so like entertainment
that anyone can enjoy and he sacrificed
his body for us I got to be real those
those jackass movies are really [__]
literally I'm not even kidding when I
say some of the best art produced in the
last generation like you put that in the
Time Capsule if you want to explain not
only the best stuff but explain what
America was like you know the last 20
years I remember going to see Jackass 3
I think it was and I was like when the
dildo comes wobbling at you remember
that no there's a point where right
before dildo is shot into I believe
bamar jer's ass I don't think I saw it
in 3D oh dude come on I think I saw it
in 2D yeah anyway yes so and I was like
this I was just expecting like this just
a dumb [__] yeah just time waster two
hours whatever and I came out being like
that was I had so much fun it's [__]
awesome dude yeah I loved every second
of that it's the best those movies Rock
but anyway here so steo was telling us
about his you know his journey of
sobriety he's been sober for a long time
and Jimmy had this to say this morning
on his official
Instagram and here it is
it
says oh no Jimmy coercing steo to
relapse Jimmy you [__] don't
leave steo alone with a bottle of of
prescription
pills why Jimmy why would you do that to
Steve I know you're a Charming devil
this the craziest thing you could ever
post yeah I'm the bad influence and then
he's sad about it # comedy # comedians
he's a doctor so he could could really
get a hold of those Jimmy listen you
need you want that to happen why don't
you uh write a prescription to me and
I'll make sure steo gets them how about
that I've been trying to get him to he
won't well he's in New Jersey if I went
to New Jersey he would a th% do anything
I'm in Queens Jimmy all right I don't
necessarily want to jeopardize his his
practice cuz he would do it that's the
thing you think he would if I was like
Jimmy just I need like a 100
fentanyl he would do it for me I think
are they prescribing fent I don't know
he'll make us mean Vic in or something
like that oh do you not get fent and all
like that I don't think so so then
maybe's no good oxy now we're talking
bro I just need like 100 oxy wow not a
pill guy you never had a pill part of
your life oh yeah no I had a I had a
semi addiction to Tramadol yeah oh
Tramadol [__] dork that's barely a
pain pill wait no no bro I've tried a
lot I've tried oxy I've tried vikin um
uh what's the blue one that's like
Viagra it's a it's the one that's
stronger than uh vicadin tradol trol is
not stronger than vicadin no it's a blue
one maybe I got little dick Valium
you're talking about Valium Val's a
there's one that's like a psychotic
there's a blue one that's those are good
as [__] too ah God damn it these these
were like the ones that everybody was
trying to get their hands on it was
called the um and trams did it for you
huh well listen I don't want I've tried
it all I don't want to I don't want to
you know [__] on your what pain pill was
your thing well I don't take that [__]
anymore it's not personal have you tried
tramol though I didn't I was pumped for
it and it wasn't that good you take did
you remember I don't remember the thing
is with trod doll it used to last so
long like I would be high for like 12
[__] that's dude yeah I would just
take you know whatever I get my hands on
anything yeah that being said don't do
drugs don't do drugs kids Tramadol is a
is such a trashy drug though yeah it is
just trash it really is so anyway shout
out to uh this really you know
thoughtful post J Le a
doctor all different flavors well I
think he he this is one of the few posts
he actually went back and erased isn't
that right guys wow yeah he got a lot of
bad he got some backlash it's a rare
occurrence that he deletes one but I
went and looked a bit ago well you know
what I changed my mind cancel culture
has gone too far exactly we can't be
silencing our comedic voice I do a in
post he's canell oh that's another thing
that peeves me is when people say
canceled and what they mean it's just
some people were mad at me yes yes I
agree with that you've been cancelled
tell me about it it has become a verb
Matt R you've been cancelled tell me
about it oh right yeah that's not he
didn't get canceled people were just mad
at his joke his joke sucked it just
wasn't funny sorry no offense I don't
know you're probably friends with him uh
I don't know Matt personally that joke I
think my position on that I talked about
this on my buddy Sam and Mark's podcast
I think if you do a joke I think you do
a joke about anything but if you do a
domestic abuse joke it has to be a great
joke and that was a [__] lazy joke
that was my problem with it right it's
like I don't think sub any subject
matter is off and that's the problem a
lot of like comedians do where they're
like they're being you know you're
silencing me but it's like no man that's
like a like a some stuff is like nuclear
weapons and you have to be very trained
to [__] deploy it you can't just like
willy-nilly try it so yeah you can say
whatever you want just has to be good
Patrice O'Neal very very well said look
at Elfin in the room has a lot of
misogynistic [__] if you just think
about what he's saying it's one of the
best specials of all time and you find
yourself being like why am I laughing I
disagree in my heart with what he's
saying and it's the funniest [__] I've
ever [__] heard true very true that's
what that's what a joke has to do I
think very true oh I was trying to think
of peret although that's perks those are
good say perets are just
oxycotton oxycodon I didn't know that
look at that dude yeah I went to school
in Santa Cruz and they were giving them
away are people there's so much drugs
there it's kind of crazy I had a bunch
of friends who were smoking heroin I
didn't even know wow yeah smoking it
just regularly like tin foil and pipes
relaxing I didn't have no idea you guys
want to come over we'll throw the game
on I used to go to their house a lot and
I was like damn these guys are chill as
[__] they just want to hang out and
[__] watch movies and stuff it's
sick I didn't realize they taking heroin
breaks it does seem like it'd be
relaxing being you know being a heroin
addict at the beginning the beginning of
heroin addiction seems awesome here's
what I'm thinking though
yeah when I'm at the end of my life yeah
retired that's that's when I'm thinking
it's time to start smoking heroin I'm
with you there because like and I'm in
and I'm and I'm just I'm being dead
serious
here how that would be such a great way
to die though aging is brutal oh sorry
that sounds insensitive overdosing is
horrible not overdosing but yeah if
you're an old person if my choice is
like oh I might have a stroke or a heart
attack any day right which is terrifying
yep I'm going be like let's go out you
know and my mind is mush anyway right
where am I who gives a [__] I don't know
what is it going to what how is it going
to damage this not there nothing to
damage there's nothing to damage yeah
I'm with you old people should do heroin
um just be f [__] sick if my grandma
was just hanging out yeah yeah she's not
waking up screaming begging to be taken
to grease if she's on heroin you know
what I mean she's [__] sitting back
watching chopped you know what I mean
enjoying her enjoying her your her yo
play her turkey sandwich go your y play
Grandma here's your here's your uh
heroin to
smoke I would love let me hold let me
hold the tin for you I would love to
spark up with my grandma I would love
you know what now we're saying this I'm
going to dose her with 5 milligrams of
weed and we'll start there sneak it in
sneak it in cut it up like a dog put a
salami put it in a salami and feed it to
her hey Nana how's that salami
tasting in a salami and a string cheese
youti string cheese uh the other Jimmy
thing I wanted to hit you with was um
okay so he's an aspiring comedian we did
a live show at the beginning of the year
oh hell and he did a set oh hell yeah I
want you to rate it I can't wait and
jimy if you're watching this is a good
opportunity for huge opportunity brother
oh at the ace I was there come on out I
know what it feels like to perform there
this was I remember your name was on the
Marquee when we were coming to set up so
you played it like a week before us yeah
wow my Essence was all over that stage
yeah was everywhere dude yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah here it is Outlaw Bring Out
The
[Music]
Outlaw hell yeah
yes Jimmy
[Music]
uh bring out the
outlaw any minute now oh that's he's
making like a Eddie Murphy comedy
special
back shimmy Lee the Jersey Outlaw
stabbing everybody up oh [__] yeah yes
dude he's the
man yes
yes Jersey
Outlaw how about that theing reception
for the Jersey Outlaw Jimmy he looks so
good how about a standing ovation I came
all the way in come on guys asking for a
standing ovation standing up standing a
surprise a standing
ovation he got his [__] [__] he got
his [__] sharpied
in anyway watch this it's so fun can't
now dude now uh Jimmy you prepared a set
for us you went to a Dominican barber
shop before got there yes I did and then
I have some roast thing I would like to
do okay just can you face forward and
just can we get a shot at the airline
yes could somebody zoom in on that it's
important all right zoom in on the
hairline oh they can see it yeah here
just put your head down a little bit
yeah there you go you can see it what do
you guys think of the
[Applause]
hairline if you like the hairline let me
hear you say yay
yeah okay where the losing natural the
losing uh team needs to come hyp up
you're the loser oh me no wow I wasn't
there let me fast forward take do you
know that cam caught a handicap guy
trying to park in one of our spots he
kicked his ass out let's hear it for
cam took a candy all right and um so
before I'm going to hand the re over to
you in one sec so there's a little
bit Yeah participating in the show
everybody was awesome you found a shirt
in the lost and found before the show
started fat guys you know it's not easy
to dress hey it's hard Hawaiian shirts
and tracksuits it's the easiest thing in
the world actually that's not dressing
up is it oh dude come on tracksuits
tracksuits don't look sick I got a
couple vour numbers yeah okay that's
true velour yeah that's fine I had to
travel that's why I'm wearing a a daily
driver track sh right now that's true I
sent the time stamp when [__] hits the
fan yeah that's what I want to show God
what are you doing you're looking for a
buffet my God look at the size of this
one oh my God yes wait a minute tomatoes
in the
audience oh that's
awesome my God what are you eat for
dinner oh my God or his ass wait a
minute the Jersey
outlaw okay wait wait wait now sit the
hell down your rat bastard Jimmy we'll
we'll give you more time that's a nice
shirt stand up young fell this guy right
here stand up stand up what time the
circus going you sure you want to get
closer Jimmy you want to work this guy's
going to work the cotton candy
machine and look at this guy stand up
stand up you want a banana oh my God he
looks like a gorilla Jesus
Christ my God
I know what's your
name you got something h under your chin
oh it's your other
chin a good one
actually respect for that one with you
it's not a roast it's a
barbecue how you guys doing over leave
the lights don't don't be visible don't
let anyone know who you're talking he
was bobbing and weaving to avoid uh
being an easy target sure wow what a
natur what a natur truly I just want to
give you a little update to what Jimmy's
been up to it was great to see him work
a crowd yeah how happy was he when he
was getting that it was smart of him to
get the standing ovation up front in
hindsight because he knew he was going
to bomb he was like let me enjoy this
well they seem kind yeah yeah I agree
but oh God sorry this is one is everyone
over the Jimmy Le stuff because there's
one I mean I've been over it for years
but you go ahead I'm Ling I'm just kid
you're over it I like to pop in person
I'm just yeah yeah over but like there's
another Tik Tok he just put out today oh
nice he actually sent this to me [__]
you got to check it out it's really
interesting stuff man all different
flavors so I'll play this and I promise
we're done with
flavors you get it that's why we love
that sound [__] man flavors that was
actually from the episode with last time
with you that's right that's right yeah
what was he talking about talking
talking about pink hot pink hot dogs
remember they got all different flavors
of hot
dogs
God I love that guy okay so here's his
new Tik Tok
yes oh he did like a stitch
moment now they Tik tocking just hey how
you doing you're looking real
sweet hey is your
daddy he feels so safe about little work
you
think leave he he us you can call me
down he looks 10 years
younger this is brutal stuff and you can
call me Daddy's wh kitten what okay
be oh
God I think the problem is job now it's
my
[Music]
turn okay yeah me just got Goosebump
sure you did hun what do you say you and
me go down to pinks for dinner what do
you say about that pink I say
poers
bingo so w this turned into Jimmy is
going to [__] this woman that's kind of
what it felt like that's where it always
goes man with Jimbo Big Jim Big Jimmy
that what's up with that girl what's
what's her deal the pro I was going to
say the problem is that that girl
outshot him right in the cringe you be
surprised girls got father issues
someone just sent a Super Chat and said
oh my God that's me so uh they might be
in the audience right now which is quite
a Twist I'm assuming that it was a joke
yeah she's very good at it okay that's
you let me go to your
channel oh yeah right watch now we love
you Katie is that really her what is the
[__] it looks like it oh my God that's
so what where is she from she like
British or something yeah it was donated
in pounds so I imagine she British yeah
uh here it is would you [__] posted this
would you [__] J Jimmy the Jersey Outlaw
Katie K is you want to go you want to go
to pinks with him they I hear they have
all types of
flavors all different
[Laughter]
flavors I can't do it I can't do it all
right
listen I'm sure that a Wing Stop you're
good what you do okay yeah a guy is
literally walking towards me right
now why does this always happen to me oh
wow I've never thought of this style of
person being British right you know what
I mean you think they when they're doing
that little like uh the Kawaii and
that's Olivia is is it kaet or auti
Little Mix of both yeah that wh oh yeah
I mean you're right well they at the at
the risk of sounding uh insensitive yeah
yeah there's a v diagram yeah yeah it's
a [__]
Circle the middle is quite there's a
little yeah there's a little yeah yeah
yeah little slices couple little slices
on the side you're right you're right
but we we love the autis oh big fan and
I love that voice and the spectrum is
beautiful I love Spectrum Rainbows are
Spectrum really nice I like all
spectrums they're just it's a beautiful
concept what about what about the
Spectrum from where it starts at not
child molester and it goes to child
molester I mean listen that's a spectrum
and you said you love all of them cuz I
don't like that one folks but Ethan
likes
[Laughter]
it you said all I'm trying to I'm
processing yeah you know you know all
spectrums are
beautiful you know and and I think that
we need to just look at it from that
show us uh you know not not endorsing
what's on the Spectrum sounds like you
are sounds like you are here first I got
your corn in there e oh [__] well okay
well hold you've been out [__] you've
been out mastered let's analyze this
you've been out debated Spectrum facts
don't care about your feelings pal you
said what you said hold on the spectrum
is a child what was the Spectrum okay on
one end it's not child molester yeah and
then the other end it's child molester
what isn't that a one and zero isn't
that a binary what's the Spectrum on
that I think
like well first of all this is the
Spectrum you love okay I don't like it
you created thisum I like it I'm
questioning if this spectrum even exist
exist there's like a guy this spectrum
was born in your mind no like groomers
versus like sex traffickers are probably
at the end Epstein we talked about it in
the beginning very end of the spectrum
so you're talking about
criminality yeah we think child child
molestation I mean listen there there's
a spectrum on child rape right I mean
we're looking at they look this is your
channel we can get specific if you'd
like I don't think there are not do it I
don't want to make it uh too
uncomfortable so I think uh but you
admit you like that either way and we're
good to go move on Nat says Ethan's
joining the war on autism on the side of
autism yeah that's not true I mean yeah
cuz I I'm on their side I'm on I love I
don't want to be against them I might be
on the Spectrum maybe so why it's a big
Spectrum well if you're on a war who's
going to do Logistics if you don't have
any autistic people on your side I want
autistic people doing my spreadsheets
you know what I'm saying so I'm on the
team I'm on the team we're all on the
team shout out to the shout out to the
Spectrum atisan not not the sexual
predator no I don't condone the sexual
predator Spectrum that's not a spectrum
that I
disassociated I don't know anything
about the Spectrum I've never heard of
the
spectrum he loves them all including
that one what I mean and the racism one
I guess too he likes that racism maybe
owner the end that's more of a spectrum
and you love that one you love them all
I do it's interesting to analyze I do
love all Spectrum drums thanks for
pointing that
out no worries man yeah yeah that that's
an interesting
conversation uh what else we got here
let the conversation
begin um where's C man I'm getting ancy
dude he's probably s sucking some guy
off in a bath house or getting sucked
off he should be you never know with him
but he he usually shows up on time he
usually comes through first oh he said
2:30 okay great oh um I wanted to share
this with the audience
um Enrique and glacius has been having
some funny media attention for basically
not being able to sing at all yeah he's
uh he is the term nepo baby gets thrown
around a lot he is one of the most
textbook examples the I mean he can't
sing yeah and he's a singer with a
[Music]
long and that's from back in the day he
was in his prime
wow yeah salute anyway his dad could
sing right well calls the whole thing in
question now oh [__] although that was
before that was before Ai and [__] yeah
but anyway beast from space friend of
the show actually made a remix of
me with the autotune that he wishes he
had
on all I
need is the rhym
Divine lost in the music your heart will
be mine all I need
is to look in your
eyes say you'll be mine all I
need is the rhym
Divine lost in the music your heart will
[Music]
[Applause]
be you'll be mine all I
need is the rym divine
something speci right there heart
beine Thank You Beautiful Beast from
space shout out beast from space so
that's our new uh that's our new
jam yeah Enrique had a
run enri he was famous as hell dating
Anna
cornova really yeah well he was you know
he was the man yeah he was the straight
option alternative to Ricky Martin right
and wello they're on a tour right now
together oh that's and all these images
and videos are coming out of him just
absolutely yeah he's the least talented
one without question Mr prob the whole
building you know that's interesting if
you picked a random person could they do
a better job there's a pretty good
chance that's fun so let's see we got a
Nook here what do we got something I
want to show you bamos that was him
right yeah Let The Rhythm take over by
Lama
Banger [__] good
song
this feeling
[Laughter]
forever that's so funny there's there's
no way that just some random idiot in
the crowd would would sing it worse than
that that's true yeah why is he
shouting that's what I don't understand
so let's talk about GTA 6 Drama Oh yeah
there's all kinds of fun stuff drama
oh there's tons of conservatives who are
angry that there's a black woman
protagonist nice Brown woman she's
Latina oh she's hell yeah and so she's a
wait conserves are mad that a that a
Latina woman is a criminal that's how
[__] stupid they've become that
they're the snake has sucked its own
dick to completion it's a [__] game
about murdering police and stealing cars
and they're like that has to be a
[__] white guy that does that
interesting
what the [__] this should be this is
they threw you a [__] softball you
[__] dumb asses that's so that's such
a good point they should want it to be
all black teenagers and Latina women if
that's you know that's their world view
that's great well so one thing I want to
say is that the the uh trailer came out
for Grand Theft Auto 6 and it got 110
million views in one day which I think
broke a 24-hour record destroyed Mr
Beast who should be ashamed of himself
be embarrassed a [__] video
they ate your ass James they're going to
make so much money 100 million in one
day I can't wait for that I mean yeah
it's been [__] what 15 years when did
the last when the last game came years
10 years yeah so but this one is looking
like it's going to be nuts it's going to
be [__] awesome yeah I can't wait to
play it with my grandchildren because
they're not putting out another one for
another 20 years probably I'll be honest
with you I never played GTA 5 didn't I
never I mean I tried it but I just
always put it down and moved on my life
I mean yeah you're how old are you I
don't want to talk about it 38 38 oh 28
though when it came out you still had
some youth left in you yeah you know I
didn't have kids you didn't have kids I
have kids now which makes everything a
lot harder yeah old man no dude I don't
know but you were a Grand Theft Auto fan
though no never and I'm a gamer Vice
City no I tried them I don't know why I
can never get into it but I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try six I'm GNA try it they're
good they're good dude five is so sick
yeah anyway that's interesting you never
got you never you never [__] played
an old one you're mad you're pissed off
I played the original one with the top
down view which was awesome as a kid I
remember thinking like this game's
amazing yeah um no you got to [__]
get a sniper rifle go to a tall building
shoot a bunch of pedestrians just trying
to go about their day just get your
steam out you know what I mean blow some
steam off right right well that does
sound
fun Zach said I don't even play games
ever and I play GTA 5 this is crazy fact
10-year-old game
last year it made $500 million yeah
online that's the other weird thing
about GTA is that it's because it it's
been 10 years the online has become this
crazy it's become its own almost like
community that they never planned people
go on GTA 5 online and just like live
full like they get jobs like they
[__] I'm not even kidding yeah they
really do where they're like like I had
friends of mine who played it online and
they would do Heist and [__] together
and then they started they would just go
to amusement parks and all their guys
would ride fake roller coasters together
and then they were like wait what the
[__] are we doing we have families we
can't be going to a fake not anymore
baby U but yeah so it makes a lot of
money online for sure well how does it
make 500 million do they buy are they
buying [__] think you're buying [__] I
there's add-ons and
stuff microtransactions it says what do
they sell what kind of microtransactions
I haven't played it I would guess like
cool masks skins guns update from Jimmy
he's he's a he's texted back seven times
apologizing 12 actually times
apologizing apologizing oh for the poe
for the steo one is that right yeah yeah
he blamed Mason well Jimmy you always do
say you're the one that posts it he has
this mad genius Mason who cooks up the
most psychotic meme uh then he sends it
to Jimmy Jimmy you posted it oh the buck
stops with Jimmy absolutely I how he
texts though because every thought is a
message so it's yo my people called me
Mason made his
people yeah he's got a team he's even
lying when he's
apologizing you don't even you want to
even go down the Jimmy Lee Rabbit Hole I
can be here all day so the wait the
game's not even coming out till 2025
Jesus Christ 25 that's what it says yeah
yeah oh my [__] god uh let's see
first time the game be centered around a
female protagonist named Lucia I haven't
seen it yet I'm pissed I should have
watched it to I'd show you but for some
reason they don't want me to watch a
trail an advertisement for a game really
they won't let you do it that's so
stupid Psy it's because of the music in
it specifically a real song nice
tracks that makes more sense I guess
whatever Tom Edy tun yeah uh let's see
it sold uh five sold 185 million units
that's got to be the best selling game
ever right it's made over8 billion holy
[__] the game rules the most profitable
ENT Venture ever one of the most that's
crazy so people are upset that the main
character is a female and a single
mother why this is their perfect you're
right this is the perfect stereotype
yeah did she also come into the country
illegally they're mad about that
too uh that's how the first chapter is
you you're work you're going with a
coyote the it's a really captivating
intro that actually would be [__]
sick you have to kill you have to kill
ice that would be fun that would be sick
that's kind of a dope you shoot ice in
the [__] head sneak over do a bunch
of
crimes that's awesome so here is the uh
backlash begins here let's see GTA 6 is
woke already hilarious this is from
gaming circle jerk subreddit why is
everyone in GTA why is everyone black in
GTA 6 not to sound racist but why is
literally every character black like
just pause at any given time in the
trailer 95% of the characters on screen
are black
sounds like Rockstar went the woke black
female route with this one I hope it's
just a bad
representation okay I'm not sure even
what do you guys watch the trailer is
that yeah yeah I mean there's a lot of
black people in it it takes place in
Miami but yeah was it was oh sorry s cut
you off isn't that what uh what was the
Franklin one uh that was in uh was that
four or three five five oh no I'm sorry
the one before that San Andreas San
Andreas that was all black people was
I'm assuming they're
representing uh the the population of
wherever it's taking place it's Dade
County I used to live there it look
pretty accurate yeah he's like yo
where's all the [__] white people
yeah it sounds woke that's so [__]
funny to be that's awesome there's not
enough white criminals in the
game respect dude and then here's
another wild post here
um oh God gamers are so racist they
wouldn't be able to handle San Andreas
if it was released today
GTA 6 looks like modernday America I
thought people played video games to
escape reality Jesus man people are so
[__] stupid man why do you give a
[__] but like it's a game about shooting
people and I like that girl with her ass
out on the hood of the car that's
[__] these are all shots from the
game that's kind of nuts those Graphics
way really yeah these are all these are
video game graphics on it look crazy
looks really good wow does this use the
real the new Unreal Engine it's next gen
it's not going to be on the PS5 and the
xbo I thought it was I thought it was
going to be going to be on PS5 no I'm
pretty sure it's PS5 dud what the hell
is it going to be on if not it's coming
out in two years it's coming out two
years yeah you think be a new
PlayStation the [__] are PlayStation 5es
for then yeah I don't think they're
going to have a new console by then
[__] they usually wait longer they
usually have like five years but more
let see Rockstar confirmed yeah it's
going to launch on the series X and PS5
oh well then Jeremy the quarter and gave
me some bad information oh what a
surprise huh that man's pisses in his
basement wait where in his basement in
the he has a drain in his basement oh
drains yeah but he pisses the thing is
do he have a little [__] but he a lot
of no he has a lot of time down there
imagine you're pissing in a drain and
it's there's a lot of Splash happening
the splash is the problem you're not
making a perfect dive between the great
holes philosophically if if he hosed it
off I'd be okay with it I just want to
be on the record that I'm okaying in the
like different perspectives go ahead
Zach look I'm 40 I'm tired I'm sweaty
I'm fat I'm overweight okay do the the
pee in my basement
one yeah my God I just peed in my
basement but anyway
um this actually got a lot I mean from
after 5 hours it had 13,000 likes 1.3
million views so people are saying yo
what's with all the black people am I
right hey what's with all the black
people and and to be clear it's not all
black people in the trailer yeah there's
lots of black people but again it it's
taking place Miami I love that it's
Miami little Vice City it yeah well yeah
it's Vice City return to Vice City yeah
it's like the The Comeback I didn't know
that that's okay buddy I love yeah I
love learn yeah so anyway uh Ian miles
Chang which I don't know am I saying his
last name right Chong ch Tong or wrong
we call me miles wrong yeah it doesn't
bite hard enough cuz for what a [__] bag
he is he says you can shoot them all now
I don't know if that's a complaint or a
no that's him being happy about it
because he there's other ones of him
saying I don't like games where you can
kill
cops that is so what a [__] [__] so
people that love sucking off cops are so
funny gives [__] here I'll pull that one
up oh here's the new Vice City
um loading
screen yo that seems so right dude I am
a Grand Theft Auto
character I belong in Grand Theft Auto
look how I'm dressed right now I didn't
plan this me the Greek is like a iconic
character yes I need yeah absolutely I I
got you know what I got two years
Rockstar if you're listening put me in
the game I'll do anything you [__]
want let me be a game let me be a guy in
the game come on Rockstar there's got to
be someone out there listening let me
get let me get honey potted by the sexy
Latina let her [__] seduce me and
then right when I think I'm going to get
head kill me that would be a fitting way
to go out love that let her steal for me
I'm a book I'm a small time
bookie um I've got it all right I'm
ready to go so let's see Elon Musk
actually tweeted about it about the new
uh Grand Theft Auto he he made this
really Brave assertion
um this guy I guess he was a hater list
of games I have not played GTA whatever
who gives a [__] isn't out yet so that's
not a revelation idiot but anyway Elon
responded he said I tried but I don't
like doing crime GTA 5 requires shooting
police officers in the opening scene and
I just couldn't do it what a [__] it's
a [__] game dude it's pixels you
[__] aren't you like the it's pixels
you know better than anyone what those
are that's where your imagination stops
is shooting fake police officers I
thought he was a dreamer oh yeah dude
dream and it's fun to shoot cops I dream
of killing police yeah in a video game
in a video game not in real life I would
never yeah should I button that or
that's clearly a joke yeah yeah yeah I
yeah going do that route so anyway um
come on man it's fun to what's
interesting is he's courted this um
gper these young conservative gper
audience and uh is that who this this
other guy kettle bell life I don't know
anything about this guy
looks like a real [__] fun guy though
yeah first of all that means you're a
loser everybody played Grand Theft Auto
yeah it means you had no friends you
never got high like I said and just
[__] got the sniper rifle out seeing
how see if you get five stars see how
long you could live or six stars even
how many helicopters you could shoot
down come on that's a right of passage
in America yeah being 13 being mad none
of you you're years away from getting
[__] so you and your friends get the
worst weed of of all time you split one
Mickey's 40 and you [__] play Grand
Theft Auto 3 that's how you [__] live
life right that's American that's
American as apple pie baby but he yeah I
mean he's he's definitely alienating a
whole bunch of people that think he's
cool some [__] Drake would say I do love
the Drake memes Drake the type of dude
that stops that red lights in
GTA so um now the same guy Ian Ian miles
Wrong by the way that guy just lives in
like Singapore doesn't he yeah you know
about him Malaysia he's I don't think I
don't even know if he's ever even been
to America that's what a [__] loser
it's like the ultimate grift it's
[__] he's such a [__] dor it's
awesome dude and yeah and he he is a
nerd he is the kind of person that would
get stuffed in a locker look at his
[__] dumb face so he he responded to
Elon and this is how pathetic Elon is he
has up back and forth with this guy like
he has talked to him they're like
friends yeah so he says I'm glad
shooting cops in cyberpunk 2077 is
completely optional I would never finish
GTA 5 oh wow again cool brag you [__]
dork yeah dude I played through this
whole cyberpunk and I didn't hurt any
pedestrians I didn't hurt any cops I
didn't hurt any cops I mean like you
could play you you can do these role
playing games as the White Knight but I
wouldn't take that out into the world
and be like I'm a good person I never
heard innocent soul in B's Gate 3 also
it's a g exactly it's a g yeah do you
never [__] you never kill the sheriff in
like [__] Skyrim or whatever the [__]
come on you didn't kill every single
inhabitant of [__] right yeah please
and I love the idea that cops are more
are more uh they're more like uh
innocent than a regular person like you
can like Ian this guy will kill just a
lady on the street but he won't kill a
cop true what are the odds the odds that
a virtual cop has hit a virtual woman
are pretty high you know what I mean the
odds of that virtual woman BR that's a
good the cops in GTA 5 aren't innocent
they the littlest altercation sets them
off and they open start shooting open
fire on pedestrians over nothing no due
process come on dude that upset me that
upsets me okay uh he got community noted
Ian miles wrong has written up 255 gamer
gamer acts articles covering GTA 5
including descriptions personally
killing or evading virtual police in
game single player mode wait for real
yeah before this guy's pivot to whatever
the [__] he is now he was like a video
game writer that was like how he got
started got known right yeah and so I
guess this is like an archive because
they're all deleted now but he wrote a
[__] ton of articles about playing GTA
and loving it [__] does he have ones
about killing
cops probably not specifically away from
it yeah okay that's so awesome to lie
about that just to seem cooler on
Twitter like a i' never kill cops in the
in the video game can I please have
cyber truck Elon that's it I I genuinely
think these guys think that elon's going
to just send him a check or something I
don't know although that wasay I missed
that I stopped going on Twitter cuz I it
wasn't as good I'm out so yeah I haven't
been I haven't been on it I just use it
to plug stuff so I but if I had known
you could get a check I would have tried
to do that I would be like damn this
Tesla's [__] awesome they a lot of
people are getting a lot of money but I
don't think that's happening anymore I I
don't know how I mean the band's broke
uh the Tate Brothers actually uh had a
really enlightened take on GTA5 oh hell
yeah and we are respecting Authority my
friends there's nothing more badass than
respecting the
police this is a real rock star what
does he look different did he get like
plastic GTA his eyes look different do
he well I don't know he's been in house
arrest for almost like a year now so
maybe he's deteriorating a little a
little
bitum guess what I can leave my house
[__] suck it I love the suit so love
how tight it is yeah any go ahead Andre
you a question I've never played any of
I believe that I played the first one
that's like a top down bird ey
viewd game loser without any me and the
tape Brothers have a lot in
commment more than I thought real
graphic violence back when I was maybe
10 or 11 or 12 when whenever it came out
I I do recall that but you know what I
want to speak about GTA 6 while while
you're on the topic cuz now we're
actually talking about something that's
relatively important video games aren't
necessarily evil but you know I remember
when video games cuz I'm very old I'm an
old man this is crazy I remember when
you used to play a little man in a red
hat trying to rescue a princess and
teaming up with your brother now
if what a [__] dumb
Mario was a
beautiful it taught kids all over the
world how to care about rescuing how to
S for royalty yeah yeah yeah [__]
overthrow the Monarch [__] Save A Woman
by beating Turtles to death with your
hands you have to [__] I remember
dodging Fireball from a giant
lizard it taught me so much this is so
[__] stupid God rescuing Purity from
Evil while teaming up for your brother
isn't a good thing of a video game that
I don't really know what is I'm not a
fan of anyone I remember pong it was so
pure there was just straight walk in the
straight line like you're supposed to in
life dude this is the exact same take
that like like [__] uh you know Al
Gore's wife was talking about when they
were trying to ban saying [__] music
like this is like [__] a repu like a
a [__] senator's wife from the '90s
it's crazy out of touch now yeah it's
just like yeah it's just like being
proper and like we can't I mean it's
crazy they're talking like white women
from the 9s right right now they have a
Facebook group called like moms against
GTA
6 um
but you know they this their core
audience is Young disgruntled men so
they've to be taking L's on this this is
a battle they're not going to win that's
it because they'll say anything it feels
too good to shoot people in the head in
a fake game that's it than to be like
well they'll be like human trafficking
is dope scamming people is dope y
whatever but then when they he comes
after their video games you don't want
to do that brother that's going to be a
problem you don't want to do that kind
of curious to see under the age of 18 21
maybe playing video games where a goal
is to shoot police officers it's not the
goal I just don't think that's good for
society with all the Amazing by the way
these guys get house arrested now like I
love the police by the way we need to
start respecting the police more right
guys how long how long are they in house
does that were they just just uh they
just have to be in house arrest inde
definitely are they still on trial
they're waiting trial they're still on
trial okay I see yeah those guys are
going to go to jail though I'm pretty
sure not looking good for them yeah I
haven't been following it but that they
should go to jail for this take honestly
this offends me so much more than no it
doesn't equally to human trafficking
equally it is equally bad yeah graphics
and engines and whatever people put into
these video games I feel like you could
create a better
objective with the game you know maybe
you are the police officer maybe you are
trying to stop and your body cam stops
working sorry car yeah as you know uh
famously through ART and storytelling
through the histories we prefer only to
look through the eyes of the hero only
and ever Through The Eyes of the hero
and that's interesting art right
right yeah who has all the power God
damn being a police officer in a game I
mean actually that would be what a g
that police officers literally do behave
the way you behave on Grand Theft Auto
you just get to do whatever the [__] you
want and get away with it so basically
is Grand Theft Auto that's so true just
go be just fail out of Community College
and go to the [__] police academy you
don't even have to have a you don't have
to play a game oh he's been he's been
released from house arrest in August mhm
I guess he's not probably okay all right
well welcome welcome back so happy we're
all rooting for you in the words of
uh Joe Biden Bugatti he said that about
Trump and I loved it so much that we're
all rooting for him shout out to Joe um
and then we move on Tim P actually uh is
has a take on this all the all the usual
suspects games in history to release its
first trailer fans have many questions
about how it will turn out a major
question is whether or not the upcoming
game will be woke which refers to a
heavy focus on political correctness and
social justice commentary I'm GNA go
ahead and pause and say yes it will
be grand theft the fact that we even
raising that question so again Tim P who
I think considers himself to be a
serious I don't want to say journalist
but maybe a news guy new absolutely he's
he's reading an article based entirely
on a
fabricated uh keemstar tweet
uh the source for this claim that uh
she's rumored to be trans uh there is
zero Source there is zero this is the
one source for this claim is TE right
right right and Tim Po wait it goes
another layer deeper than that because
Keem actually showed his Source if you
want to uh what's his Source his Source
was here I'm opening it right now oh and
then he said by the way this is a weird
posting so weird he says she she's
remember to be a female prot uh trans
and then he said
wood I mean yeah fair enough that's the
one thing I've agreed with this
[__] on all day oh then somebody
says what's the source bro and he says
Google is free he Googles GTA 6
transgender just a post from and it
comes up a post from one year ago Grand
Theft Auto 6 first ever female
protagonist is a trans woman and then
you click it look at this zero zero
[__] engagement
[Laughter]
that's
awesome wait this is the way back
machine this is a nothing Post Yeah the
post got deleted but I was able to dig
it up on the way back machine and uh
yeah there's like and there's like two
comments three
comments and uh so this was the source
and Tim P now who I'm sure hates fake
news yeah uh more than anything in the
world is so funny being a grown [__]
man and being so embarrassed of being
Bal you have to put headphones over a
beanie every day this isn't something he
has to do once we all know what you're
doing he wakes up he's like well time to
put his beanies have [__] headphone
marks on them that's [__] pathetic
dude like we know your ears aren't just
getting cold or some [__] we know what
you're doing bro yeah come on man it
brother believe in yourself Tim so true
I feel like anything they anytime they
remake something they just are like and
you know what this needs some gender
query and just some more LGBT like is
this what anyone who plays this game
wants people have already commented when
that doesn't exist it's just straight up
fake news manufactured fake news that's
what you're doing right now from
gar yeah well you know what my theory
about the beanie is is he wears it
because his skull is open to
the it would reveal no brain in his head
yes it would give the game away yeah
yeah
damn it looks like he not been aging
well actually yeah and take it from
another guy who's not aging well yeah
dude nobody neither of us look good but
we believe in ourselves we're just who
we
are take the beanie off how old is
Tim uh good question also you know how
he's badass he has a [__] has a gun
and a and a samurai 37 all
right anyway so shout out Tim P who's
doing really important news breaking
news yeah yeah yeah um what if a fake
criminal was trans what if a video game
criminal was trans that's an hour of
discussion that's where that we got
enough out of that that's good stuff
let's say let's see the quartering put
out a video titled GTA 6 trailer blasted
as woke and angers fans for another
reason GTA 6 crushes Mr Beast record too
oh um Jer which you want me to watch
this one B specifically think all right
cuz it leads into the next one you're
talking about Miami you're talking about
downtown Miami it's not like there's not
white people there you know um that
exists but uh you know Miami is pretty
brown the guy who pissed in his basement
he also [__] his pants in Walmart right
Zach yeah can you play that one yeah he
did he did already no no I was just
saying he there's [__] all over the
floor yeah yeah I don't think we have
the full uh story have story pull that
Zach it's important
yeah
um you know although I wouldn't
say I mean they' they've gone with the
um how do I say
this hold on I see white people yeah
there is white people I do see white
people yeah and yeah there there's
plenty in the trailer it's just there
are some black people yeah that's that's
enough for people to be call where is
the best place to [__] in a
Walmart bathroom right that's what you
but he determined it was actually in his
[Laughter]
pants that's [__] awesome yeah so
he's uh the quartering has left his
suburb and uh he doesn't like the colors
he's
seeing it's all very off already taken
my pants off the good news though is
that oh he's not happy with the jiggle
physics I thought he would like that
knowing him interesting a a a
convertible by the way I saw this um you
know a little you know I'd say a little
light on like jiggle physics you know I
would say that but it's enough you
definitely have goodlooking women Jesus
Christ honestly he's right they could
have jiggled the tits could have [__]
bobbled a little bit but they have
they're still two years to work on that
we got time to get the titties bouncing
we need Dynamic titty mhm realism
absolutely although she if she's got
fake breasts which it seems like they
jig different they would they would
jiggle they move all together they'll
move the same amount but all together
let's Analyze This
Again a convertible by the way I saw
this um you know a little you know I'd
say a little light on the jiggle physics
you know I would say that you definitely
have good-look women um but hey you
could it's Miami it could all be
silicone silicone doesn't really jiggle
okay but you know I think you lot of
it's not this man doesn't even know his
way around titties man I'm not going to
listen to this guy it's just a matter of
real titties are like diffused the the
whole thing Jiggles and it moves in a
wave pattern it's fluid whereas fake
titties are kind of you can tell where
the where the fake titty begins although
there have been really great uh the
technology has advanced recently but at
the same it's just a different kind of
jiggle I'm not going to now I'm pissed
off okay this guy's coming this guy's
bouncing titties I don't know where the
thumb down I stand with science by way
but I would do it and I'm I'm Pro
science I'm Pro fake titties there it is
thank you that Enlighten you thank you
thank you thank you you are you know
what you are a philosopher of modern day
philosopher thank you yeah yeah certain
things wait hold on
dude yeah I am you're right comedians
are important I bought the platform
about the game it's obviously going to
oh how about those tities those jiggling
you know kind of yeah show us try to be
more uh
modern what the [__] was that he has his
own voice changer yeah she's listen the
protagonist hot is that her no oh that
wasn't her
no um
[__] dude well Jeremy is going to
miss there's rockar used to have a no
like a nobody's off limits kind of thing
jokes I'm sure that they're no longer
going to do that I'm sure there's not
going to be any quote unquote jokes
about trans people or minorities or gay
people these are things that would have
probably existed in talk about just
getting pissed off it's not the game's
two [__] years away it's [__]
crazy dude and they will do that they'll
have a [__] chance channel will they
make fun like that's the way they do it
they make fun of the type of media I'm
sure there will be like a you know like
a like the radio shows were the funniest
things because they would they could say
under the guys of under the guys of
satire they could say [__] [__] up
[__] on those radio stations this guy's
a [__] dumbass dude this guy is it's
uh Jeremy he's our boy is he the guy the
guy who piss he pissed in his oh and
then also what did you say about crotch
rot you know you get that crotch rot he
said you know how you get crot rot rot
yeah rot like his is [__] what his
crotch is rotting damn dude it needs to
be crotch rot it needs to be removed
[Music]
surgically
we got that yeah we got this button by
the way I like that that's nice every I
looked over and everyone myself yeah
yeah yeah so it goes back in time 20
seconds nice this thing like an old
radio dump that's exactly what it's so
important oh I'd love to get one of
these oh my God I I wish I could carry
it around with me in real life it's been
a game changer hell yeah it truly has
been yeah that one probably wouldn't
have G I know it's just like being a
[__] parody of yourself where you're
like mad about
if there's [__] if you don't if a
character doesn't get to be racist
you're getting mad about that two years
in advance and then you're like H the
titties could have been a little better
you know what I mean it's tit not bouncy
this guy's doing a pro like for fat for
fat shans he's not doing he's doing the
community wrong well he's actually he
has quite a successful YouTube channel
Alex for uh conservative grift them oh
it's conservative like gaming [__] yeah
culture War gaming [__] like he post
like five videos he posted yesterday
Starbucks goes woke goes broke [__]
ridiculous still talking about Dylan
mulany had a video yesterday about it so
how many is that at like the Bud Light
100 like I'm not even that's not even a
joke it's got to be a 100 oh he's still
talking about Jesse Smet this guy's
[__] and then oh that one actually
did well for him too so the people are
still and what cracks us up every time
is he's still using this [__]
screaming
girl uh not Charlie Murphy thank you
though the screaming girl meme from like
20 years ago yeah dumb yeah tough stuff
yeah it's tough I like to I like to
provide an alternative if you're a fat
piece of [__] be more like me man that's
what I'm trying to do here I'm trying to
be you can
be you can be horny you can like titties
you can like video games but just don't
be a [__] thork about it that's all
I'm say that's all I'm saying you can
say you can say risque jokes just be a
good guy that's it it's not too much D
I'm [__] myself here's the thing let
me talk to Fat teenagers the way they
need to be talked to because I was them
once you will not get [__] if you
follow this man you may get [__] if you
follow me that's what I'm trying I'm
giving away the game for free dude
that's so my whole life I'm trying to
provide the blueprint for incels we can
get you out of there brother you don't
need to be involuntarily sell it you
could just take a [__] shower don't
treat women like they owe you some you
know just be a nice guy wait around
you're going to get rejected a lot but
eventually someone will be like hey
that's a nice guy he [__] took a
shower he got a new shirt he's not
talking to me about anime he's he's got
another thing he doesn't have crotch FR
he his crotch is not rotten at all don't
follow these [__] they're
charlatans thank you that's what I'm
trying to tell you I've been wondering
how do we reach them men you know
there's this huge Market Jordan Peterson
and the tap brothers and all these
[__] people that are harvesting these
uh young men with all kinds of valid
anxieties yeah uh and channeling them
just basically have them upside down
like a like a High School freshman yeah
taking all the change out of their
pockets and I'm I'm always wondering how
do we reach out to these people and put
them on a better path and I think you
got I'm trying dude sh yeah watch the
special and then uh go to listen to
stavi world it's an advice show and most
I would say my podcast is 60% like young
insecure men calling in and most of the
time the answer is like just you know
take a [__] shower buy some new
clothes and have some interests and just
be nice and that that's really it it
will work if I can [__] you can [__]
that's the motto yeah and and I would
say when you're talking try to be
genuinely interested in like what
they're interested in and not not in
like a patronizing way but like if you
find something that she's interested in
that you like take interest in it listen
you know engage with it in in a real way
yes absolutely don't get mad about if a
criminal on the game is trans don't care
don't bring that up who gives a [__]
bring that up at dinner trust me dude
you will never get laid no actually
speaking of
dating cman is Mia huh wow no no uh he
emailed me a few minutes ago and said
he'll be hopping on shortly so uh pretty
soon here yeah so speaking of
um of uh dating life gurus this guy
honestly he's not the worst but I find
him endlessly fascinating his name is
maybe
um
Timothy
Creek and he's he's like a newborn
Christian SL Jim rat and he has got like
the most interesting uh wisdom to share
with the people who's this guy he's a
he's a a god he's a a Christ War Warrior
he's he's yes okay big time let's see he
chased he makes motivational videos for
young men love it yeah do we chase
people God would give us people we don't
have to chase we're going to have
to let it rep whoa that's [__]
awesome you know maybe if we chased God
as hard as we chase people God would
give us people we don't have to chase
holy [__] I love that man that's good
advice that makes a lot of sense that's
really youthful advice yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm I'm going to that why is God
running away from you that's it why do
you have to chase God is antithetical to
the whole idea I thought he's [__]
carrying me on the beach when I'm
[__] tired now I got to [__] catch
him which one is it I thought the
footprints were his not mine absolutely
make up your [__] mind pick a lane
people we all need to relax he says
let's
listen you relax on a plane even though
you don't know the pilots you relax on a
ship even though you speak for yourself
bro I'm [__] myself when I'm on a
plane who's [__] relaxed on an
airplane I I actually am I'm well I'm on
pills yeah you know what I mean I'm
unedible I'm [__] got my eye mask on
yeah if I got a Pog full of xana I'm
zoned the [__] out plain I [__] if I got
a plane poag Xanax I love flying yeah
it's [__] sick just sit there with a
whole bunch of people one time I took a
red eye yeah one time I took a red
eye and I I was so pilled up I just
reclined my [__] and uh it was from La
New York and I was and as soon as I like
reclined the steward started like being
like Hey sir and I'm like [__] what the
[__] and then she's like we're here I
was that [__] up that it was like a 5H
hour flight I [__] slept right
through it it was [__] awesome there
it is I missed my little Delta cookies
but that's all right nah yeah we'll get
them next time I do like a I do like a
bis cough did you ask for one before you
left yeah I'm like on the way out hey
hey
T yeah H me up give me a couple hand
fulls of biscoffs um I guess maybe
that's what he's talking about maybe he
was blasted on Xanax and
Som you relax on a plane even though you
don't know the pilot you relax on a ship
even though you don't know the captain
you relax on a bus even though you don't
know the driver bro you're making a lot
of assumptions about these vehicles yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's been a lot of
catastrophes totally on all one of those
man also public transit if you're
talking about a bus I'm not reling on
the [__] bus I got my head on a
swivel those things be rolling off Hills
like daily y or the school bus
everybody's [__] making fun of you
you know what I mean you you don't want
to be yeah school you know no this CRA
you ever seen when those like kids
school buses crash and the kids like hit
the roof look like they're F they hit a
bump yes horrible man what are you
saying right now where's he from do he
like Belgium or something he's South
African oh come on the most racist guys
in the world that's like [__] that is
a country that's so racist they were
like hey man you know I don't feel like
taking the slaves back to our place why
don't we just move here and make
everyone in the country slaves that was
South Africa it's more convenient yeah
it's they're so racist and con yeah they
they [__] moved an entire continent
to be racist they're like this is where
you go to get racist that's awesome and
they stayed and then they're now they're
making [__] dumbass motivational
[__] Christian content uh go on uh
Timothy why don't you relax in life
knowing that the almighty God you know
is in control so again terrible advice
like imagine you're in Uganda and like a
[__] you know a Hut that's like half
full of water yep uh you live in Still
Water right I've seen videos on Tik Tok
this guy goes to like the worst I've
never seen anything like I didn't know
people live like this where people are
living literally in Still Water damn
that's mosquitoes probably [__]
hatching like it seems
so rough but anyway why don't they just
chill dude God's in control bro God is
in control you got to relax bro don't
wipe the don't even put M mosquito
repellent bro God's got it it's in
control God did but he does Fitness
stuff too or I don't get it yeah yeah
he's Jack he is jacked nice so that's
cool I like that about him here's more
he's not the worst though he you know as
far as these Alpha influencers go it's
there's something gentle about it he he
yeah he he's more sincere
year I think
less aggressive he just he just loves
God he loves God and he he thinks that's
the answer to people's questions which
you know that's your thing uh can you
guys pull up the classic me like yo me
and my Bros are going to go out oh yeah
the club another one yeah you know not
everyone has to like you in for having
being disliked by some people is a sign
of a healthy relationship with yourself
it means that you're being your
authentic S without adjusting your
behavior or personality to match
everyone's taste okay after all the
quality of life is not determined by
your popularity but by your ability to
form meaningful connections with the
people that love you for who you are
that's actually not bad advice bro pre
it's actually I think he's kind of pre
it right there dude from God's mouth to
my ears brother I'm with you Teemo yeah
he's he's got some good moments actually
we love Teemo um he got he went viral
from this clip or I guess they're
looking for it I'm looking for it oh
there you go so [__]
funny bro let's go out this
week you're gonna love
this
here go ahead Tim bro let's go out this
weekend there's a crazy event happening
there'll be a ton of chicks let's just
go have fun and let go a little and let
go a little and let go a little no no no
no no no stop stop yeah that's the wrong
one it got me so hard yo bro let's go
out to the
club did they bully him into deleting it
maybe here I'll find a re oh that's a sh
I like the ones where people are
reenacting it like perfectly I've seen
some dudes like perfect frame for fame
bro let's go out this is event bro let's
go out this weekend there's a crazy
event happening there'll be a ton of
chicks let's just go have fun and let go
a
little and then in his real video he
goes That's what you would say if you
hadn't found God we found it you got it
oh yeah he turns it all upside down dude
that's [__] awesome Camy can we got
it oh this bro let's go out this weekend
there's a crazy event happening there'll
be a ton of chicks let's just go have
fun and let go a little yeah that ain't
my kind of fun you know what's fun for
me W is this going to get claimed I know
this this is a
song we've played it a bunch of times so
I think it's F ear hitting the gym
spending time with my Creator building
the life I desire spending Creator sound
like you have [__] lonely ass hanging
out with your mom sitting in an empty
room yeah Mom what do you mean version
of myself every damn day so if your kind
of fun is getting shitfaced over the
weekend that's cool but we don't do that
over here we're focused on God what's
over go and growth you can't go out one
weekend hell no you can't get a little
[__] nope let hell that's the worst you
and the Fellas can't go meet a nice gal
at the club what's wrong with that that
could be your wife true you don't even
have to have sex with them if you're
going to be a [__] you know Christian
dork about it but you can still go have
a [__] little little you could you
can't even drink once you can't
celebrate uh why you worried about my
wife this is really beautifully put
Photoshop can't fix a wack
heart damn dude that's so true you know
how people are photoshopping their
hearts yeah you know people try and pH
their heart ckg or whatever what do you
call itg EKG yo that EKG is looking a
little shopped buddy those lines are
looking a little too nice having a good
heart goes far beyond having a pretty
face because at the end of the day of
course it does it got nothing to do with
it having a good you know ugly people
can have good Hearts
too wow that's so interesting there's no
Photoshop for that and if you have a bad
personality or a nasty attitude no fter
is going to fix that [__]
true true he's not that bad he's just
spitting facts he's just honestly he's
on one that's
awesome
um he privated his Tik Tok a that makes
me feel
sad that actually does make me feel sad
come back makes me so sad come back Tim
come back we love you te Timon Timone
like Timone and buo teone come back
teone baby sad hell yeah
dude C man you're killing me where are
you where's shean I gotta talk to
shean bring that dick over here bro is
he [__] is he I'll let you know as soon
as he pops in he told he told coming the
world serves at his pleasure that's you
know 30t of
cement treating us like a we're in the
bath oh he just emailed me and said give
me about 8 minutes eight minutes all
right
for eight minutes I'm to talk to she
give me eight minutes uh so what what
can we do in the meantime we should
watch these we should watch these
Russian basketball players dude okay
this [__] this shit's pretty good I'm a
big hoop head let's see wrestle ball is
a Russian sport which recently got its
own professional League it's a mixture
of basketball wrestling and rugby hell
yes interesting F yeah Russia's
innovating the sport is said to have
been invented by Russian wrestlers and
became official in
2003 with uh with it since spreading to
Holland France Czech Republic and
Eastern European countries okay so this
is really something played on a padded
basketball court that aims to score into
the basketball style hoop but the no
contact rules have been ditched and
wrestle ball let's go [__] you [__]
somebody up [__] each other okay let's
see what the Russians have cooked up for
[Music]
us wait hold the phone how was that how
was how did he already shot the ball
man how does that add and one that's
awesome I'll teach you to throw that
ball that's aw yeah why didn't you just
tackle him are they just trying to
injure as many people as possible to get
him off the field I think he would say
it was a late uh he he missed his window
but he was trying to just [__] stop
the shot he he oh yeah I'd love to see
more
gameplay
that's right
[Music]
bro
damn okay so can they dribble I don't
get it it's padded I guess they don't
dribble they run with it cuz it's like a
rugby thing yeah I guess so you got the
hoop you to see more I'd love to see
more have some more videos yeah and I
got to mute it wait you have to take
your shirt off that's the second guy who
took his shirt off he's taking it off to
tackle homie you got the muted Zach oh I
another the exact
same oh my God that man did not deserve
that and they're folding him in the
[__] head who that was dude he F he
folded his spine dude what the
[__] what the [__] is going on what is
the point dud Russia and why is Tak yeah
he's like hold on bro I'm about to
[__] paralyze this guy I'm going to
look sick though yo I'm about to put
this man in a wheelchair
all right what else what I need more
yeah we got more oh wait so I'm I think
I'm reading that the rules involve
taking your shirt off wait for real you
can throw it in their face right Dan is
that what you're reading uh you can use
your shirt as a
weapon no it's that remember use his
shirt to like
stop I just sent a clip that's called
t-shirt defense attempt all right let's
watch this one since I got it up well
this is a different they're in a octagon
yeah what the dude they're all just
about the
suplex cuz they're trying to kill each
other I think oh it's like halfcourt
three on three and you get to [__] each
other up dude this sport is [__] dumb
yeah I love it oh juked his ass swish
that was good [__] respect are they
allowed to do anything but suplex each
other I'm trying to find some official
rules actually tackle them like a
football tackle that seems like it would
be dude this guy's nice with it though
he [__] just switched okay okay
oh
[__] oh [__] I don't know I would watch
this this is pretty sick pretty cool
yeah maybe you're right you know what
I've been really into at least I watched
the clips on Tik Tok but I think it's OB
the slap [__] the slap League that is
crazy yeah yeah yeah that's a little
much for me that's straight permanent
brain I don't enjoy that at all I mean
I'm just morbidly fascinated by it I
mean holy it's kind of they are [__]
each other up and their faces like
[__] ground beef after yeah I've seen
some yeah totally like a cartoon
character I've seen some people let's
see so what is this uh what is this fun
t-shirt defense yeah the T-shirt defense
you can see he takes off his shirt and
tries to throw it in his face why do
they look
Amish they have like Amish bangs and
like the little underbeard I guess it's
a chin beard yeah maybe yeah there's a
there's a overlap between the and I
think there actually is out here an
Amish wait when do
where does he take the shirt
off there it is that is so silly why not
just have keep sawdust and sand in your
pocket yeah yeah they just [__] she
he wasn't even a part of the play and
he's suplexing him I love it I would
love to yeah he's like what the [__]
man oh dude a beautiful sport though
here's a full play we can see yeah I'd
like some unedited gam playay let's see
yeah oh they wer in singlets in this one
it seems like the court style is just
walk as much as you want and you can
block and those guy there's two guys
just fighting in the back and this is
not padded this one's not ped if there's
a suplex on this and why are they not
stopping them I don't understand look at
everyone is just coupled up and
wrestling and now they're just fighting
look at these guys they're just
wrestling oh [__] so you can just block
them no this needs a little
standardization he's in a headlock oh
wow that's got him in a headlock you're
right it need we we need we need more
rules yeah I literally just I I found
this walking into the office reals just
fed it to me and I was like oh this is
interesting oh nice dude oh that guy's
just [__] him up they're not even
part of the
play he's and he's mad at the ref for
stopping him he hit him hold on he hit
the ref was that that wasn't like a hay
pat on the bat I think it was a slight
swap let's see let's see that again yeah
this guy's just [__] a guy up bro the
game it's not even close the ball has
moved [__] uh guys can you just
at least pretend to be interested in the
game he's like hold on I'm trying to
kill him
yeah he's like y's what the [__] bro
yeah yeah yeah yeah somewhere between a
hit and a
protest that dude is scary looking
though yeah all these guys are lunatic I
don't want to get choked out by anything
unpadded
basketball
damn oh oh they are suplexing on the
hardwood
and they're just stopping the [__]
look at this is like this is like what
basketball used to look like when I was
eight just rolling down the field
everyone's chasing after oh whoa he just
hit him with a forarm the other guy what
the hell hit it none of them can shoot
either what are the actual rules I
wonder damn dud that was pretty nice
that was clean these guy it's funny they
can Sho can ball
yeah I just hit my balls let's see oh
nice I love the tra they don't [__] with
dribbling no no no that's my fa yeah I'd
love to know what the rules around
traveling are wow Dan you can can you
bring the volume back maybe oh yeah hold
on KOB got his
[Applause]
ass oh they knew Kobe Bryant greatest
slam dunks oh let's watch that that
sounds awesome I think I think it's the
one does the behind the back [__]
sick um in the
meantime CP C man C man I have a
favorite podcast that I think we can
learn a lot from i' love to I'd love to
learn name is fidus I'm a lifelong
learner have we reached out to fidus
have we made contact with him yes we
have fidas with a d he's he's a cypria
oh he's a c he's a
you know I think so yeah he's got like a
deep accent and [__] oh I love that so
he does this um really [__] up Social
experiments that's how we found him oh
yeah like he did one where he was like
um surviving in Skid Row pretending to
be homeless in Skid Row for three days
or something and at one point he like
stole a sleeping bag from a homeless
person oh my [__] god dude cuz he you
know he's out there living the real [__]
it's real what do you do the real thing
he had one where he was in uh
Japan and their goal was to travel
across the entire country without
spending any money who so he was like
getting on trains without paying hiding
in the bathroom he got arrested three
times that's awesome he um was stealing
food from buffets Hotel buffet just
being a piece of [__] yeah what an
experiment so anyway we found out he has
a podcast I love it oh c man's here yes
all right [__] whatever fit is nobody
cares yes I need to talk to C man all
right give me a second to set it up in
SEC this is the moment I've been waiting
for link me his podcast CH shorts
Channel though as we wait I don't know
how long it's going to take C man to get
off no no he's uh he's here he's locked
and loaded one second yes oh oh take
take that off take that off hold on hold
on yeah he's he's going to need a minute
hey can you hear us C man I hear you I
don't see fidus in any of these clips
bro but who are these people trading
stocks versus gambling okay let's learn
so I do day trading you don't think this
is pure gambling yeah it is kind of a
speculation you don't call it gambling
but you call it a speculation the way
that uh you want to stay away from
gambling you I see man yeah we can hear
you buddy can you hear us what's
up we can't see you though there he is
hell yeah so C man uh can you hear and
see us okay I can hear and see you can
you hear and see me I sure can yes sir
oh who's this dude by the way what's up
man I'm stavos what's up oh yeah I've
heard you were funny thanks man you
heard yeah I like your work yeah thank
you thank you it's cool well it's good
so uh C man let me introduce you guys a
little bit so stavos here very funny
comedian in fact he's got a new special
on Netflix you might want to watch uh
fat Rascal fat Rascal yeah fat rasco
that's funny I thought you would do it I
thought you would be in it Ethan but you
know you were the fat rasco one point
right yeah well I still
am he does Ean look like he actually
looks young I thought the man was in his
70s poor bastard now he looks good you
know [__] Jesus Christ Hey Hey Hey
listen little dick Rascal let's tone it
down here with this EXC little Ras I
probably got him packing more than you
are not based on what I've seen brother
I'm I'm coming out on your
defense can I just say C man I we we
were looking at your [__] earlier and I
was in I was on the team that you have a
bigger penis than Ethan thinks I think
he can reach pretty nice told him the
whole thing is the whole thing is it
depends on on how big you're gonna be
it's the mood in the timeing you know
see man but hold on explain your explain
your um tantric penis increasing
meditations cuz that love to about me
and maybe you'll understand I'm a man
who would love to incre spiritually
increase the size of my penis so tell me
all about it I can't say I'm spiritually
increased I'm just saying is that when I
think about things that turn
ont turned on you just Edge for hours
and hours and hours of course because
you know what I noce some people are
turned on they don't stay in their mind
like yes their penis is hard and their
stuff stiff but if you keep the thought
in your head that I'm going to keep
doing this all damn day instead of
saying I want to be turned on hard for
three or four hours and I wanted me stop
go to the bathroom watch watch the movie
and get hard again right no I'd rather
continue my my my lovefest and that's
what I mean by staying hard hold on I
now I have inter I have to go get pizza
or
something can I'm Sor I don't want to
come and do your interview but I have a
lot of questions well first I let me ask
one which is do you pee when you're
fully Tor because you said I'm going to
go to the bathroom and come that's the
funny part I I guess the weird things I
have to get soft because no man in the
right mind
Comm sense men you can actually hurt
yourself so what do you do um right I
don't know I just have to not think of
sexual things and just think of things
take and I go soft and I just go soft
right and then I have to get turned back
on again so I rather just make sure I
just don't have any interruptions during
anything sexual I hate that like that's
the problem assertive yeah yeah so I'm
just wondering so you're trying to get
hard so you're saying you don't want to
do the buildup of the the no everyone
got buildup but the problem is is that
you're ready to climax you know you want
to go you want to shoot you know but you
had to go to
the or something stops but how many nuts
are we getting off with one heart on
what's what's your what would you like
to do cuz you're talking I measured my
nuts I just know I've P oh sorry that's
a that's a that's a it's a sling I'm
sorry how many bust how many
ejaculations ejaculation I would say
probably two times cuz you know I'm 49
it's not like I could do it nine times
when I was young could two times and
then I'm exhausted sometimes I mean holy
[__] I felt like I ran a marathon I
don't know what the [__] and this is
[__] me but the thing is you just
sometimes at this age you're not going
to you know run like the Energizer Bunny
sure sure sure sure sure um because I
don't mind a break is all I'm saying is
this a Master break is always good
everyone needs a Snickers you know I'm
kidding I that's a good point nuts why
not you yeah um you know are you talking
about master marathons or sexual
marathons with just sexual and
masturbation cuz see the funny thing I
masturbate certain times but I guess I
could do without touching myself I could
come and blow a load but the problem is
that depends on the moment doesn't
happen every time I get turned on with
somebody it's just I'm really super
extremely turned on like maybe it could
be something about the person then I'll
just start exploding but it doesn't
happen happens sometimes what are some
of these attributes that'll make you
explode
handsfree just having a hot moment with
really a hot moment because sometimes
you get have a hot moment with somebody
but it might not be like you feel it
like the chilling you and you're like
this is totally wild you know you know
I've been wild with people but they
didn't get it and I got it but when they
get it and you're both enjoying it the
same time make you just erupt like
mountaining Hill yeah absolutely I have
a funny story I have a funny story
because I was pissed off today because
you know I the biggest thing I hate
about the day is the [__] GPS yes
tell me about it you know the stupid
thing 300 feet turn left 300 feet it
gets you lost I'm not about to say 400
feet your [__] fire you stupid [__]
and 500 feet you need to shut the [__]
up Jesus you can M that thing man you
can I really hate these GPS and it's fun
[__] up hold on hold on hold on C man
you can mute
those how do you do
that you're the and are we talking about
a Garmin or are we talking about Google
Maps no w w yeah there's usually just a
microphone in the corner that you just
tap don't you drive for a living I do I
I drive but the thing is is I know where
to go where I'm going but today I was
all the way out Long Island in suffer
County and you know I know some of the
roads but it was like Kings Park hun I'm
not calling you out for not knowing the
road I know then I was on like [__]
mon Highway almost country and like
Bohemia and then it weird thing it goes
from Bohemia to like Seldon which is so
far away and then I'm and then I'm going
to like freaking Northport and and East
northp so C man I would I I have to
M age I agree it really messes it's hard
you know talking it's super
hard Jero minola Boulevard in minola but
the problem is that's a long distance
and then you're H all freaking see man I
would recommend just muting it yeah cuz
I I know but I just want to throw it out
the window I'm like you know you're a
stupid [__] I keep tell no I got you
don't even know New York you tell me oh
go left go right you know it's like you
put it on C man I mean you put the thing
on you asked it for help I have a
question C man because do you think part
of this is that it's a woman's voice
that's annoying you you know could there
could there be something kind of uh
psychological it could no it could be it
could be a guy it's just that it's just
annoying because it's like a left right
here it's like you don't where you're
going I know where the hell I'm going
but I'm just why it see man if you knew
where you're going you
wouldn't
cuz I saw traffic on Northern
Boulevard I want to get on the long is
express
way like you needed help from ways
fig way it TT me on the one tour and it
takes me to se for the Oyster Bay
Express all the way out of my freaking
way and I'm like I'm never gonna finish
the damn day so I finally got home and
I'm like this is craziest day I had you
know it's weird I don't the thing was
that's nuts I I was going to tell him
that I I don't know about you know about
my dildo store that's a new thing I
haven't heard it we we we've actually
been anticipating it and looking forward
to it well the way to think I bought
this gift at one of these sex shops in
Manhattan uh it's a you know you know
you know what a dildo is with the rubber
peen sure I'm sure you're aware of okay
yeah um and what happened was what's a d
though a rubber penis basically you know
with little balls on them you know um
the weird thing is I bought this one
right for a friend of mine he's like
over 60 and in Florida the best I want
to make him feel good you know I guess
when you get a certain age in the life
is kind of over poor best I don't know I
was J he's 61 I feel bad 61's pretty
young still N I know I'm for I'll be 50
in two weeks but I look great for 50 you
do I'm just saying you could still be
[__] and part of my act I don't want
to hurt people's feelings being 60 but I
was like oh my God I'm what did you buy
a dildo for just as a joke right and
what happened was it was I kind of
brought it in to see if I could test it
out a bit but even I don't like to plus
I was like whatever but the funniest
thing is the directions were hysterical
it's like you know one open up the
package make sure you know do this
number two is you know insert mouth and
and blow on number three was this and
number three sit on the right way and
it's like number four make sure it
doesn't explode I'm thinking myself what
the I'm sorry this inflable dildo or no
you could plug in or you have batteries
right because I usually get there with a
battery one but it's like it could
explode and it said intense heat I said
what a stupid [__] thing I meanone
knows penis don't explode I mean my does
of course a real penis would explode but
not because metaphorical sense exactly
and left my ass off so I tried to return
it but the it was They Were Somehow in
the Philippines are calling up at some
weird number and I'm like you know they
then they want to give me a smaller one
I'm supposed to exchange it for an even
exchange and I got my friend a 15 I got
my friend a 15 inch right wow 15 in you
think his 61 year old's spinter needs a
15 incher you're trying to kill him I
don't I don't know I I but then she I
they said you can get only a 9 in who
the [__] wants a tiny little thing you
know all right see man now now you've
lost me he's out of control by you're
trying to just slip in here that 9 in is
a little dick we all know that's a good
sizable dick seen his 9 in dick and in
his world N9 Ines is actually 4 inches
sorry manway s they want to give me
actually a 5 inch or six inch penis
actually you know what can I ask your
permission for something C man if you
will permit us can we tweet out the
photo of your deck so the audience can
see it and and then we can get kind of
the audience's opinion because there is
a lot of maybe later maybe
later but hold on hold on they wanted to
exchange this to me for a 4 inch penis
it was a small one right and I was angry
because a foot like that's like about
this small and I'm like not what four
inches is
man this is kind I think we're getting
the heart of the matter we're getting
the heart of the matter C man does not
know what it is inches I know what an
inches I passed math okay I so how tall
are you how tall are you I'm 5 foot 11
okay oh nice okay 11 inches right you
know what that means yes it's almost a
foot okay okay just they want to give a
small penis right because they don't
have a big one in stock apparently was
the last it's kind of funny right so I
said you have to go back to store to it
like did you just dunk your phone into a
glass of water C man this stuff happen
we we lost you we lost your audio got
weird yeah you're back I have Spectrum
it's really bad my
wife
anyway so what happen absolutely so what
happened is that they wanted me to go to
the store and I said why can't you mail
it right to the person so I'm calling my
credit card company and they're telling
me well do you want to dispute a charge
and they don't want it was older I said
no I said it's a rubber penis I bought
and she didn't figure out what written
on the credit C I don't know what the
hell happened to the damn thing but
anyway um so now I have to try to get a
smaller one and give it to my friend I
me I don't okay I think I don't think
he's going to get mad but I was trying
to test it out and I was gonna try to
deepthoat the freaking thing and it
didn't and I had a problem with it it
didn't work I put the batteries in I
this is an important question did you
test it before gifting it well I was
going to but then was broken because it
didn't work with the battery now what is
broken when it comes to a dildo because
I don't know I've never had a vibrate I
don't want we need batteries cuz I would
think it's basically just you got to put
it in your ass or your mouth and that's
no you put the this one this one I got
you press a button and what does what
does the button do vibrates I guess it
vibrates in the ass I don't know I stick
it in my ass I put my mouth to see I
didn't do it man can I ask you a
question so stupid who the hell
instruction penis hold hold on on gives
instruction for a penis hold
on hold on C man hold on do you think
that your friend would be pleased or
displeased if he knew that you had test
drove his sex toy that you bought him as
a gift beforehand I he would have got
mad I wanted just to make sure that it
been okay I mean I would have cleaned it
with alcohol and then rewrapped it all
other right right do you so you think he
wouldn't have minded that you sucked on
it beforehand now was yeah let's answer
that first I'm sorry I I don't know I
honestly don't know now here's here's
what the difference is for me were you
hard when you were sucking on it so was
that were you getting pleasure at it or
was this more scientific to check it out
for your friend just like tasting uh
scientific I really wasn't really turned
on by it because I try to get on turned
on by real penises not not rubber stuff
but right I just figured you know my I
really never played with p with with
dild before I mean I used to joke around
but I never got one in my ass I used to
watch people put in their ass really
like I don't think I want that in my ass
but it's just so weird he gives you I'm
I never thought the dumbest product in
the world I called him up I says how
stupid why would you give directions who
the hell needs a direction for a deal
like never maybe in the Philippines they
don't have penises I don't know they
got Vietnam we know that well I know
they do yeah for sure but it was just
weird because it was like why do I need
directions like one two three four step
process and it might explode if it gets
to I'm like what the [__] who the hell
like that's now I got I actually have
another question because you were trying
to test it out and you were trying to
see what would happen when the when the
batteries worked like you trying to I
put the batter in the se but actually
vibrated now why did that need to be in
your mouth to see if it vibrated it's
kind of wasn't in my mouth I was going
to test that before I put I was going to
put the vibrate in my mouth you said you
put it in your mouth man the I just
tested it out without plugging it in
without the battery in it the mouth he
said he put it in his mouth he did I put
my mouth just see like so you did put in
mouth
yeah did it
was anyway it anyway I'm just tired so
um so where's this story going or is
this it well my my thing is I'm just
pissed because if they're gonna return
it give it a equal value or the same
size but to tell you only can get a four
or five incher Fair it's like it's like
the song don't want no short dick man
don't want don't want you know song I've
heard that song 1999
song Pretty
so this that's the
story well yeah but the funny part was
instructions and I called up I said why
do you even have instructions for a
product that's it's the dumbest thing in
the world why would you even make
instruction like you don't know how to
use a penis see man I noticed that you
you had complemented my appearance when
you first came on how what do you think
about yeah because I can't believe you
look that young oh thank you so much
must have done something no I didn't I
just lost weight you want to rate me do
you want to rate me uh C man on a scale
of 1 to 10 you're still a five I'm
always number nine wow are you talking
about my feet or my appearance just in
general I'm just oh can I ask you you
know I would love to know what you think
about my feet CU I have these big wide
Fred Flintstone style feet I never I the
weirdest thing is I've only had one
person Fred footstone feet and I just I
don't know I don't know what to think I
has I I could see it show me show show
me show me what it looks like so what's
the best way to take maybe take photos
and send it or do we just put them close
to the camera oh yeah they are Fred foot
and stone feet well it's interesting
some guys like that I mean it's pretty
big it's pretty wide thick it's a thicki
11 and a half 6E the widest that's
really big bro you could squash somebody
with that I could is there a market for
this could I be a Barefoot guess I there
are there are guys that do like really
wide feet like I said I've only had one
guy once I mean his feet weren't bad but
the guy was just a complete [__] I
just really didn't get guy so C man get
you rated all of our feet can you rate
stavros's feet I think they're pretty
nice i' say six seven I
mean I'm not
used big wide feet though I'm not used
to big wide feet but I appreciate that
because you can put your personal uh
desires aside and objectively rape my
feet and I really appreciate that
they're not bad they're not they're not
bad at all so hold on C man what would
you do to his feet if you could I don't
know what I do I don't know if I I don't
know I mean I don't know what else
depends if we share a moment would you
want to watch him
drive would you like to cross him in the
bath house or a car what would be more
if he's driv you're getting way too
personal take me out of it take me out
of it she man take my feet on a cute guy
that you already put you know what I
mean your type you don't have I don't
have to be your type just put my Fe say
but I'm just saying that's just a little
personal too but I mean I shared some
personal stor but depends on how Wild
I'm going to get you know if I'm eating
having my Del supply of banana of of of
watermelon fruit blueberri strawberries
raspberries blackberries made pineapple
that helps and what well no it's always
good to eat healthy during the day you
don't have time to eat a full meal you
want to eat healthy snack and fruits
healthy and that gets the [__] going
well it gives you sugar and natural
sugar is good for
you C man can I ask you you've your
frequent contributor to the show and a
fan favorite have you in the outside
world uh interacted fans have you had
any sexual encounters with any fans no
I'm hoping to because kind of I actually
did meet this girl in Brooklyn
ironically I stopped in Dunkin Donuts
and she's like you're she goes are you
see man I said yes said then she we
talking she was really lovely she's like
really I met her in um Brownsville was
was Brownsville Eastern Park only met
one person on the street eh yes I was so
happy she's like you're great keep up
the good work and I think someone else
might have because somebody took a
somebody walked by with a small camera
and flashed up my car and I don't want
take a picture of my license plate but I
saw it it was in Long Island near the
Roosevelt Field Mall um it was really
scary because I was at a red light and
somebody was just walking by I guess
going down a sidewalk maybe on in
Westbury an Old Country Road and it was
really weird because you know I
sometimes go above the crosswalk because
when I drive I don't I sometime go I'm
trying to make the light it get yellow
and have to run the yellow because in
New York there's cameras everywhere it's
like man we actually we have a photo I
think of the encounter you had and
apparently what
happened no what apparently what had
happened was the person walked behind my
car and they stopped they took a picture
of yes isn't that nice that was me and
donut she said you want to read what she
said I'll tell you she says I was
running errands on my day off and
decided to get some Duncan Donuts camman
walked in and his energy was undeniable
I knew it was him I finally got the
courage to say hi and he let me know
that I was the first family member to
recognize him in person had had a cute
little chat and we went on our day he
was wearing flipflops hell yeah yeah
that wasn't tooold there was a 56 degree
day weather it was warm the other days
before that was really cold so I just
figured well I want to go back to
feeling warm get the toes out while you
still can well I fig 55 is warm for New
York and other states is cold you know
but the thing was so but back back at
the other one with the light when I was
at the red light cuz I tend to always go
past the crosswalk which isn't good
let's get back to this right you know
the thing is and I guess the guy was mad
because I he has to walk behind the car
in New York you know people do it all
the time because over and the person
stopped though and looked at the car
maybe they recognize my white monster I
don't know it sat there I think
something was in his hand but it put a
phone or something like you better not
be take a picture of my license plate
creep because I don't want that's
personal that doesn't sound like that's
from the show though that sounds like a
personal I'm saying but come on why
someone must have recognized me in my
car and my white Mazda come on the white
Mazda is a powerful automob you keep
saying yeah but when I said it last time
and I do auto parts and I'm all over the
place and they saw me sitting in there I
had the same look see man what's the
sexiest car to
drive I don't know I think I've driven a
lot of cars in my life but I personally
like certain cars I like at Toto Camry
the new one that the Camry that's just a
working one I did drive though was I
would say recently was a Dodge Charger
the new one that's nice you like I mean
they're gas eaters because the're big
engine but you know I I feel powerful
though you feel powerful well you know
you want you want a masculine tough car
but car I like I like gas efficiency who
can afford to fill up gas see man I mean
sexy and like if you're in the shotgun
and you're you know pleasuring yourself
and and then there's a hot I've done but
if you could choose one maybe not a to
of Prett or one of those other little
tiny you be cramped
you that big fat [__] those want space
to move that [__] around those Fiats
those Fiats you know it's like what are
you in Europe you suck at [__] in Europe
no but Americans Drive the Fiats at
their pansies and know go I'm so cool I
drive a Fiat or I
drive [__] [__] drive puses a real
man drives a real man's car understand
C man have you had any recent romantic
encounters that you would tell us about
no I've just been so busy I'm trying to
get one really anybody open I'm
available when's the last time you had
an encounter with
somebody I would say probably March of
last year
met wait see man I never talked about it
but it was a bit romantic March actually
this year 2023 see man this turns our
understanding of of who you are on its
head I mean this is a serious
drought and it was just like it was in
the village okay hold on hold on sorry
maybe it's the wording romantic sorry
East Village not W Roman places are
completely you know people get yeah see
man I think the Romantic threw you off I
meant just like a sexual encounter not
like a romantic encounter oh yeah I blew
load on his feet walking went to Deli
and then we talked and I mean he had a
nice fck
any foot guy's GNA blow a load on
someone's feet they absolutely brother I
mean but I I did in his apartment which
was pretty wild um that's the wild part
is that you up his apartment because the
apartment was the thing was I wasn't
going to go to anybody's apartment that
I you know strangers it was really weird
because this day and age since you know
the world change the last years people
are afraid to bring people to the
apartment you know and back in the day
you go to anybody's apartment within two
minutes was normal you know and now in
New York everyone's so scared you know
but every I'm afraid to even go
so C man when was your last sexual
encounter I would say probably March 20
oh so it's the same 2023 this year that
last one because I played March that's
three months C man that's not three
where how about we're in December oh
wait oh I thought eight month you need
to add man you m need to get nine months
nine months n months see man you need to
get you some
dick you know I'm trying some Arch have
you ever lubed up an arch and [__] it
have anybody has anybody held their feet
together and you [__] their feet some
guys do that ironically I I don't know
it's weird with the [__] and the on the
feet sometimes I mean that's OD I've
done that a few times like I've done a
lot of things but you know you stick the
[__] between the the feet I still try to
get between the toe but you can't W the
toes that much but I mean people are
very creative you know anyway so this so
I I need to kind of figure out what I'm
gonna do going forward so the footage of
a
Target what it's more of a the foot is
more of a target for you not really the
thing you [__]
well you he likes the way it looks
because there's no hole in the foot you
know that's so F I mean you can make one
C man you can put a hole in anything you
know that's kind of weird yeah that's a
little weird let me ask you a
question tell another story funny right
hold on tell another funny story am you
are you are um I have to ask you because
this
knowledge that you the last time you had
a sexual encounter was in March is
really
changing uh I think everyone's
perception of of who you are I was under
impression that you were doing having
sexual encounters daily or if not multi
times a week I was some are you somewhat
of a monogamous guy huh well I'm not
monogamous I'm I'm waiting for the right
person but I don't mind fooling around
because I am single but the problem is
that a lot of guys I meet either are
dating somebody and are happy and I
don't want to be breaking up someone's
[__] relationship [__] wrong all
these fak people that going up there
trying to say um know I want to meet you
but you know I kind of seen some seeing
somebody's different because you're
dating dating you could dat as many
people as you want have fun when was the
last time you went to a bath
house oh that's a long time has usually
when I travel like to Florida or Vegas
I'll go somewhere there because you know
so C man what's happening how okay I'm
just confused because I thought you were
you were doing shooting these pornos all
the time and well they're not porn for
I'm shooting foot but I mean I I
sometimes depends on
the sometimes it depends on the shoot
you know we're hanging out time you did
a sh you know I've got when's the last
it was July and there was no that wasn't
a sexual encounter no it wasn't we just
in the car doing driving videos and the
guy's boyfriend just you know I get
turned on by the feet and watched him do
his boyfriend's feet in the car but did
you jerk off of course I jerked off i ph
all right so I mean I would I would
consider that a sexual encounter I'm
with I mean sexual by in bed with
somebody when I mean sexual I don't
consider jerky me just the last time you
met with another person and did
something where you cmed well on one of
the shoots I did before that like the
last year shoot I did I really talk
about it too much because it just
depends and we just had a little how
about this how about this the last time
somebody touched his penis is what I
would like to know okay is that March
yeah it was about last year on a shoot
but you know we're getting really
personal yeah we don't have to get
you're right you're right you're right
I'm sorry the last let me ask you
another question when was the last time
you were in a space with one other
person or more where you
came so probably my my shoots because
obviously I'm shooting them I'm
directing but I'm also coming I'm also
acting him so I probably that was pretty
much it so yeah and that was I'm having
another anyway so I'm having another
shoot coming up gonna be probably be in
Vegas because I found a space we can do
a video shot get all yeah I got a lot of
cool guys who want to be it so it's
awesome be sometime the end of January
early February in Vegas because Vegas
great place I'm also gonna have another
one in Florida after that so all right
things are looking up yes how do you
meet guys C man if I mean well I have I
have a talent search that helps me which
is good like any adult industry they get
people for you and I also have people
meet me somewhere on Reddit or or sexy
jws my ad but Reddit I was actually
surprised because I actually met a
couple good people on there because most
I'm trying to get off Reddit because
Reddit is very fake and robots and
people are [__] cam artists and
they're all like married straight [__]
up people um so you know I just can't
believe it's getting worse with the
straight people on there I mean I'm
sorry but the straight guys got to stop
[__] with us because I've been I just
had a big argument with someone the
other day yeah this guy gets up and goes
I'm Jing off to your feet I'm like no
you're not dude you're [__] with
you're a straight guy you're married
don't tell me you're jacking off to my
feet and not jacking my off of my feet
the whole thing the whole conversation
with this guy was I'm straight I'm
[__] straight I'm [__] straight
I'm like stop saying that you know if
you want to enjoy the moment but you
know you're ruin it see man why do you
think he lied to you about jerking off
to your feet why would he lie about that
because because I looked at his profile
and it was all about like [__] he
like bashing game you know why are you
even on these things but then why was he
talking de youal what was he looking for
I don't know because these these weird
some weird thing straight guys have this
weird sick [__] mentality they want
to [__] with game man but you know it's
[__] he could have been a very
deeply closeted
man not say I'm not saying it excuses
his behavior I'm just saying you know
it's closeted people still tend to be
straight they don't really need people
need to do anything sexual with men some
do some don't but many but I'm saying
but a lot of times we I get straight
guys that say well I might have saw you
from the show and I want to I don't want
to deal with them because straight guys
you know you're never going to be able
to have a relationship with them because
what if I do like them we like each
other you know you can't you can't [__]
around them the one thing that's you
know a lot of gay guys have this problem
a lot of gay guys are fed up with all
these straight guys getting into stuff
they don't even know about I mean you
know you you know it's just weird you're
not why you even doing anything with gay
sexual time it's got to end it's
ridiculous you
know get the straight guys out of gay
porn I'm with you brother well I mean I
watched a lot of things and I actually
was had a discussion with somebody about
this I actually met somebody who was who
was an actor and he he was going to act
like me but he told me I'm not gonna act
to those straight people I said I don't
have straight guys in my business I
don't want them in my bus because we
were talking and he's like I love
everything you do but he's like I'm sick
of how a lot of I'm not doing hardcore
porn like I'm doing foot he said you
know there a lot of gay a lot of
straight guys that you're basically gay
fubo for porn for us by us the thing is
there's a lot of gay
going porn and the problem is it's
hurting our right I agree with you had
mentioned on Reddit that it's too cold
right now for driving videos why is that
no I didn't say it's too cold for
driving videos too cold to walk videos I
drive barefoot all the time it feels
good heat summer and also some do socks
videos but I said it was too cold to do
a walking video because somebody wanted
me to driveing and walk out of my car I
said I would have drove and put my shoes
on on my on my my flip-flops but it was
9 degrees that you know and then
someone's like someone had a challenge
with me which is cool a real man how
strong can you take the cold weather and
I say well I was at Rock away I was
going over this Inland hav't been
Rockway in a while and I what road did
you take to get there uh the Bel Park
where I think it was the um um forgot
what it was it was a bridge I had to go
over this bridge which I remembered some
time yeah and it was one I and I was in
Rockaway actually Bell Harbor um going
from Howard Beach was quite funny and
the thing was is that it was cold and so
you know I had this person on Reddit
says do a video and I did a video day
before on woodhen Boulevard in Queen but
it was only he has that subreddit um so
the but the problem my walking barefoot
in New York Long Island well because I
was on the other one um in nle county
and the thing was I was the thing was I
I I didn't
want hold on C you post 47 degrees
I'm curious about the interactions here
this is your post my feet walking
barefoot and then there's two comments
but they're all you yes always because
well hold on let me explain to the
audience because the person who let me
explain to the
audience your one first comment is yes
always hot to see barefoot walking down
the block you said about yourself and
then you responded to yourself and said
thanks no I was respond to I was
responded to this other guy that
responded to me who's from Australia but
he kind of got off that because he was
like saying he he does it all oh he
deleted the comments so he's made you
look like a lunatic here no I maybe look
like Lun I was responding to him but the
thing was he in Australia because he go
barefoot all time which feels great good
for B but the thing was it was too cold
so I said 50 is the I'm gonna go and I
had some guys tell me oh you're a wimp
you know you strong feet you know B man
go a little cold I'm like I hate cold
weather but I've actually knew guys who
go barefoot at 24 degrees but them
that's [__] cold that's what so I was
that was 51 which wasn't too bad so
let's let's cut listen we've got through
the niceties let's cut to the to the the
meat here the girth of it um can I tweet
the picture of your
[__] I mean you picture my no that's I
think C man I think what I think should
happen C man should get the most torqued
picture of his [__] possible you should
get yourself you should do a little
meditation you should get your dick as
hard as possible should I whip it out
now I
can show us it's not a wreck it's not a
w oh God this is
happening oh my God his pants already
off wait how did you get your pants off
so fast you're not in frame you're not
in frame C man not a
wck hold on move your hand hold on let
me let me take a look C man I didn't get
a good look at that's that's a nice hog
hold on hold on I didn't get a good look
at it C man nice ball
hangers just leave it on camera for a
second all right you got to go down a
bit you got to move the camera down okay
now but don't touch it either I can't
see it oh okay that's a you know I think
that thing get pretty
big yeah well I'm sorry I'm not turned
on cuz it's really no one worth that's
goodlooking enough for me to get jerk
off hey that's fair dude it's each his
own you know I mean yeah I know teach
that oh my
God that's awesome anyway so I had I had
a funny story because I was trying to
hold
on tell you
look I hate I hate cell phones okay I
had a problem with my phone again the
other day it pisses me off I hate
GPS happened was I bought a cord it
didn't go in and I kept telling I hate
when that happens charer I'm tired of
paying $25 so I called up and said it
doesn't fit in the [__] hole and I'm
upset a T-Mobile right iron ironically
you probably heard that a few times in
your life with the
hog so what happened
was I had to buy Six Chargers and they
never fit right and I had to
buy and it didn't [__] hole we need
some there needs to be some level
of recip cation here so my question is
we saw the dick and thank you for
showing usk I wasn't a see I
wasn't never turned on I understand but
so the there's a picture one public
video that you made it's you with two
dudes and you all are having a good time
and you pan down to your dick real fast
so that's the photo is going to ask for
your permission if I could post it to
Twitter so that the fans can share their
opinion on the size of it they one share
the Pet's fine I don't mind you could do
it
just like I said is the whole the whole
whole thing with me was I just went off
what someone told me like I said I've
never measured it I don't go around
measuring myself I think that's juvenile
but not juvenile it's just odd if
someone likes you they're gonna like who
you are and I am fairly nice size I'm
not like I'm I'm not like a little tiny
little thing I'm not I never
said yeah yeah I'm not like button or
Eminem for God's sake Jesus so hold on
so so guys so there's two moments one
there's two time SE pans down can you
grab a still of both cuz I think they
both offer a different unique
perspective two different perspectives
is good well if you want to wait come
back 10 minutes I'll find a por and I'll
show you how W I would you see that I
have to go is the problem I got to go
pretty soon oh [__] I I would I would I
would love to look at your hard but I do
have to go soon unfortunately I would
yeah is that okay with you guys yeah I'm
not I'm where's the HR department
yes well he's calling my phone I have
been silent you got to go I'm tired
Chargers I'm tired of buying chargers
for my phone you know because this these
phones keep breaking how about you go
get your dick hard makes a lot of money
off $22 charges it's a lot of money it's
a [__] scam but listen go get your
big card and let see see the hole of my
phone I had to buy seven of them they
still don't fit my phone is dying I have
I can't charge the damn thing I'm so mad
at [__] T-Mobile until I got Sprint
but I got a Sprint but I had a T-Mobile
phone so Sprint I can't get the charger
and sprink because T-Mobile phone they
make them this way called said I told
the woman in the phone I can't get in
the damn [__] hole give me a better
charger did you try putting a dildo in
there no you can't put a dildo it's
little apparently listen Okay so we got
you so hold on C man one sec we're gonna
say bye to stavos and I'm glad you guys
had opportunity I love this a great
great to meet you C man thank you for
the generous rating on my feet that was
really really nice I really appreciate
that watch the special please see man
it's on Netflix right now yeah check it
out it's uh do you have Netflix C man I
can get it I have get you can get a hold
oh yeah uh thank you guys this was so
fun thanks for having me watch this
please watch this special fat Rascal on
Netflix right now I had a remember these
are the two we're going to Tweet out I
remember the fat yeah go ahead go ahead
love yeah all right guys we are TW and
put the not safe of course of course I'm
not so guys so here's what we'll do c
man in terms of uh the erection or not
uh yes see saos I'll send you I can send
you the picture and then can you call or
you doing I have to I have to I have to
get hard first I have to find hot porn I
can call in a different day if you ever
want to do a a a seaman kind of
retrospective on his [__] and I can I'm
I'm going to fly out one day and
surprise and being I'm not giving you my
address I'd love to be in the
studio no I'm kidding I would I think
that could be fun a fun interesting
experience uh that Dan I think Dan is
most of all excited about it than anyone
um but I will say this here's what I
want to do regarding the uh erection I
want let's tweet out these two photos
and let's see the the doubt or lack of
in the audience I'm upset with the size
if anybody wants to give me help and
they know what the size I didn't measure
that I just pretty big okay I'm happy I
think it's a nice [__] I think it is too
I'm actually happy no hold on this hold
on this stems I did not this isn't about
the niess of your [__] this stems from
the claim that you said between 9 and 12
Ines well that's what the guy taught me
and I never you know looking at 9 12 in
you know what 9 and 12 rer well that's a
big you know what a foot long a Subway
foot long sandwich looks like yeah well
I'm sorry but you're you're he the
moment you don't sit there and go back
to math class and go gee was this this
this right that's a good point eyeball
it's like being in a fire hydrant you're
trying to eyeball how long of a distance
you need 15 feet to not get a ticket
right so you're eyeball so you're not
going to go out and actually measure
with a tape thing in New York City see
man there's a big difference between
like six eying saying I'm eyeball
situation or I'm 7et from the hyd you
know what I mean cuz I did that one day
I actually got out with a tape measure
people thought I was nuts like I'm tape
measuring the distance from the because
I don't want to get a ticket it's
85 in New York City for a ticket bro all
right thank
you fake meter not the cops it's the um
see you next time I'll keep you updated
it's the fake um the fake cops the NYPD
traffic which are not real cops they're
fake cops they're like want to be so
hold on first of all before we get to
that and I'll give you a moment to prove
yourself if if that's what it comes to
no I was just kidding I'm not gonna do
I'm not gonna jerk off and show my my
penis W on it I'm not gonna do that I
was just I was joking around oh it
didn't seem like a joke I would I would
view
it yeah I don't think I'm okay because
you're a professional performer but okay
obviously I don't want to course you
could I mean I could but it's going to
take me a while I need to at least have
a half hour to like get turned on wait a
half hour yeah I was stuck in traffic
dude you know New York traffic is at
5:00 really I could have played it
myself in traffic I thought about that
it would have been hard getting on the
show all right let's I play with myself
when I drive sometimes all right so hold
on uh We've tweeted the
photos Okay and now we're getting some
feedback from the a I can't even see the
screen I want to see like the what are
you seeing on Twitter and the responses
I'm seeing some responses in chat people
are saying um there's some people saying
it's I hate to say it but there's people
saying it's small some people said nice
[__] I'll give you that um some people
say of course it's small because I'm not
a wreck no no guy is gonna be big when
they're not a wreck I mean it's real so
there you go it's a regular penis
mushroom mushroom penis a lot of people
are saying they saying they're saying
you have a mus a nice mushroom T cuz I'm
cut MH simp I how to be cut as a baby
right because when you're Catholic and
you're baptized Catholic you have to be
cut but so at least you guys can know
I'm not trying to be mean here I'm just
saying I was I was under the impression
you said 9 to 12 I was expecting like
the hog of the century well that I mean
I looked big when the guy told me maybe
the guy was off his me I whatever
because I was the Heat of the Moment I
didn't go down let's go measure it seems
like the consensus I'm seeing is but
maybe five maybe five inches I don't
even think it's is it five well like I
said at that time it wasn't that hard
but after after that I went further I
didn't do the full video of the rest I
was erected later on takes a while to
get erected that was only the first 10
minutes of what are you saying on
Twitter love what's the it's shot it's
it's not it was to be to the smaller
side people are saying that's fine
that's fine but as later on I didn't
film me fully record as I didat I got
you all right well the people the people
have seen the evidence I have the people
have seen it takes a long time to get up
there and if you want to come back in 30
minutes that' be fine with me it's up to
you well we could see how well I can get
I mean I have to really yank it hard I
mean I you know what we don't have to do
it we don't have to do it yeah cuz I'm
saying I was prepared if I knew I was
prepared and I was turn on I would I
would even show you me coming that okay
I didn't ask for that I didn't ask okay
hold on I didn't ask for that I know but
I'm just saying I had to be prepared for
these kind of things all right don't
just expect to walk in and be like okay
you know people don't just randomly get
hard unless they know for the moment's
right know I mean crybaby says if that's
nine inches I'm 67 well maybe cry baby
is 67 because I haven't I don't know how
tall they are though she appears it
appears to be a from what I can see in
her photo not a tall
person all right C man anything else you
want to
add um no not much I mean I don't know
what else I mean really like what else
you had stavos who else did you have on
the
show no you don't have to do it you say
what what' you
say what are you doing
what are you what are you doing what
happened C man you good C man what
happened did you lose
us C you meditating on the Spectrum C
man C man yeah I'm looking at the chat
up but okay but you're on the show we
gotta keep yeah I am I'm come on I'm on
I I can still see I know I can see all
right so um yeah yeah starus we have
guests occasionally he's a very he's
actually a really quite a famous
comedian so that was a nice and I had no
idea he was a famous comedian mhm very I
don't know I
mean yeah he's super famous he has a
Netflix special out right now that's
Making Waves actually it's trending next
to Seinfeld on Netflix it's trending on
Netflix that's pretty good
right
[Music]
is so production what what so there's a
rule on YouTube that I can't promote a
URL that goes to
a site that has um sexual content but
what I can do because I know you want to
promote your stuff and I want to support
you we can
probably how can we I I'll put it in the
chat I'll put wait hold on don't put it
in chat what can we do put I'll put I'll
put it okay you know what see man don't
put it in chat we we'll we'll tweet it
out how about that no I'll tweet it I'm
I have I have Twitter I'll tweet it on
my own Twitter okay but then we'll
retweet it because I want to I want to
help promote you and then and then also
I'm also going to put it in just the
comments you know the comments of gets
in there I I mean I can't control that
yeah I can't control what he writes
right I mean I can't believe that they
they can't let you comment on that's
really crazy I mean there's like no kids
here it's not rated G for Christ sakes
this is an adult show it is an adult
show I agree I I wish how dumb you know
I wish that we could do and say anything
man it's just not right you probably
have some crazy Holy Rollers going oh my
God I never saw a penis before you know
pretty bad um what's your Twitter so
that we can so we know what to retweet
maybe you can send it to Dan can you
email it to I can send it to Dan I'll
send all my stuff to Dan I'll send it to
you all right see man I'm so I'm so
sorry to hear that it's been so long
since you've had a well you know I'm
also picky and that's the problem I'm
very picky and I shouldn't be picky but
I am I guess at my what you look for
a lot of things I look for people I just
look I guess there's a lot of different
things I'm looking what are what are
like um what are um education Vibe
Killers if you're like I'm out this
person has this attribute I'm out what
you besides besides Fe obviously they
must love feetness Common Sense secondly
um they must be wild and crazy want to
get into a lot of different awesome
stuff but they gotta be real and genuine
but nobody seems be real and genuine you
meet someone turn out that this this and
this and know they did this and that and
it's like you know they could have broke
the law I want someone who's who's
genuine real someone who's dedicated to
to what they are for what they love who
they are as a person and someone that's
got a brain that's educated someone that
wants to have fun and do things not be
like a bump in a log and just sit there
I met people like I just want to sit
around and drink old damn day I'm like
you gonna drink your life away you know
you know I sto drinking I stop I know
that there's a per there's a perfect uh
twin flame out there for you there's a
perfect anything for anybody out there
if they if they work hard to find it but
my thing is I'm just I rather work and
try to work on building my business and
work on trying to meet really cool
people which I've met some cool people
in the last couple of months good when I
was on some people on Reddit were cool
well and Reddit like I said I'm trying
to get away from Reddit because there's
a lot of fakes and you know I'm just
sick of the straight people that are
going on there trying to say I want to
[__] with you first of all you know you
you know you won't even admit you're gay
because no straight guy is ever gonna
sleep with another guy honest to God
it's the god honest truth stop being in
denial out there you you [__] nuts and
and if you're really saying something
just say look I want I want to do
something but sit there and [__] do you
use the apps or anything like that I
know that no I don't like apps I don't
find I don't like dating apps I'm old
fash I think you might do well on those
just I but they're all they're all fake
and they're all Bots
people Bots and fak I heard that grinder
is like super popular uh in the gay
community and act yeah also it's a mixed
a few things a lot of times either super
young or they're super old and you know
and it's also that makes sense up thing
that I found out that there was a lot of
pedophiles on on that and I I got I'm
like yeah some creep some creep
contacted me thought I was 16 I said
dude get the [__] away I'll call the
police on
your I don't [__] tolerate any of
that stuff how long ago was
that about two about a year and a half
ago two years ago I went back 16
yes because I had my I put an old
picture of me when I was my early 20s
modeling it's an old 1999 modeling see
do that you can't do that you that's
called catfishing though you have to use
a you have to use a recent photo of you
or people get angry I'm gonna show
AO an old photo of me when I was do I
don't know if he thinks we can see it
he's going he's
saying give him a second is he talking
to us he
is you know what I like I like a
house I love a yeah me too at least a
room
tour I'm trying to find photos of my B
but I'm really proud of my old looks um
where is my photo people are echoing
what he said though older men try to
pray on young boys on the app it's sad
that is sad that's gross wow okay hold
on there's there just hord people
thinking 16 here we go here we
go all right let's see
it that's what I looked like when I was
20 that was 1999 my little um Guido look
wow St yes yes I was modeling in a
Russian company they stole my
information
I something huh you know um yeah but
that was me I looked really but man you
can't use that as a photo for what you
look like today no I was joking on on so
you don't look 16 in that I joking I was
joking on the grinder and what I did was
I put this up my old photos of me from
1999 that I do modeling in New York City
um and the guy go oh you look 16 I'm
like I'm not I think I was let's see 73
83 93 I was uh how old was I uh 20 6 I
think 26 27 and this see looks really
good so that was me I'll show you
another photo of me this is love can you
or love I don't know why call love sorry
love I don't know where that came
from hold on
um um C
[Music]
man looks Coy those look like School
photos frankly like High School photos
certainly not 16 this is a this is a hot
photo of me in Lauderdale Florida that
was 2000 that was me wow 23 years ago
huh yep I'm really good there and then
this one was a pretty hot one of me in
in my um modeling I was doing some 2000c
I had the suspenders and the other one I
was wet I looked good one in my 20s
didn't I can I ask you something uh do
you do you long for the uh times past
you seem to be you seem to be focused on
these old photos of you yeah in 2000 my
model my first beginning of my modeling
career I look pretty I'm still hot now
do you wish you could go back to that
time no necessarily I I I'm enjoying
going into my 50s because you know what
you have to get old someday and can't
you know I have the memories and I have
the beautifulness of what you know being
young was everyone could say the same
thing everybody that was the movie star
in the and0 back to you know that's good
but you know I always I I said the
reason why I put the old picture on
there was a joke just to see you know I
didn't mean because I wasn't looking for
something serious this guy goes you're
six time like you're a creep get the
[__] away from me I don't do that sick
[__] [__] see man of your apartment
I'm curious to see what your abod is
like not apartment it's the house this
oh it's the house show me around my room
oh so are you sharing the house with
others or is this my mom's house my mom
my mom and I alone only she's 80 years
old a
so oh that is a that is a
revelation you're living with your mom m
cute have you have my mom is old and
sick and she a couple of months ago She
fainted on the sidewalk and I thought
she died in Hill had to come on the road
she just fell and I had I had the call I
had a drive from the bushw I had te I
thought she died so it was really hard
for me was struggling the last three or
four months cuz she's got like aib and
all these other problems and dizzy can't
walk and the problem was is it was in
Richmond Hill of1st Avenue we were close
to Jamaica Hospital took 45 minutes for
an ambulance to come because apparently
there's a shortage in New York City of
ambulances which I was pissed off at so
I said no take her to you know Bo moral
Hospital the or New York Presbyterian
where my father died and I don't want to
go into some shitty hospital and she
went overnight and they said it was just
because she was dehydrated because of
her aib so
so I was scared so you know I had to be
home from my mom I've been home 5 years
and I came back from Australia and I had
I was hoping I would move out my mom but
my mom got sicker and sicker and sicker
and she's been really not in great
condition so I'm stuck staying I mean I
so how long have you been living with
your mom there for five years I came
back from Australia five years you been
taking care of her you're a good son
that's nice of course I am I'm a good
guy it's the most
important
nice yeah have you do are they helping
out at all they do sometimes that's good
but the thing is my mother's the most
important in my life because also people
have to realize guys out there have to
take care of their because I see a lot
of guys when they get older they just
let their parents go don't care about
helping the mom your mom raised you
brought you into this world give give
her love take care of her that's a
message that's a nice message your mom
because I lost my dad and my I had a FL
my father died in 09 but take care of
your mom and your mom is you know should
be important to help her out and I see
how cruel guys are I understand you know
it's boys and you know boys are close to
dads Because a man and women are close
to moms but when you when you have a mom
and it's only parent left don't treat
them like [__] treat them with love
because they brought you into this world
they give you everything like my mother
always says now your TR to take care of
me we took care of you so yeah it's hard
it's hard for me that's it's hard it
sounds like a difficult situation but
I'm happy to hear that you're doing the
right thing there see
yeah and I want to show you what I like
to show me around your room though so
show me about around your space then
let's take a look at
it um that's my airplane my Virgin plane
I got back from Australia because I love
planes I that's an that's an 83300 it's
296 people I'm G not like that like that
you know I got this when I was visiting
Malaysia it's a it's a a stone um Muslim
thing Stone um thing here I'll show you
right there see right cool that is cool
s these are all my other pictures I was
thinking about when I was a little kid
this this one I like that one of me
showing my chest when I was in my 20s
really H that's a good one that was a
good one um so that's pretty much
there's the air conditioner cover
because it is winter and then that's the
window oh that's my golfing trophy when
I was in Catholic High School I was
golfing I wanted to be a golfer I was
very good I was were you yes I love huh
and um I was trying to be a pro golfer
but I never kind of continued because I
wanted to be an airline P I thought my
parents I couldn't afford to send me to
fight school so it was always my dream
that you know I see the planes flying
over my school and queens going to the
Guardia because I went to high school in
Jackson Heights Queens Catholic High
School I the plane to Runway four and
was
Runway over Grand centr which was
actually 22 oneway South 2 who likes to
watch the planes but my parents like
know we can't afford it middle class you
know can't afford it middle class and
I'm like it hurt me so I end up just
going to school getting a random TBR r
on film degree and then I went and got
my masters in international business and
I got a degree so um but I never forget
planes I love planes so exciting to be
in a plane and traveling have you ever
off in a piece of machine have you have
you ever jerked off in a c no I would
like to though actually actually no I
take that back because I actually had
the funny thing is I actually went when
I was in Florida in 2000 when I went to
this flight school they had a simulator
and I was kind of joking around I was
also turned on I saw this really cute
guy and you know he had flipflops on and
took him off to go into s simul because
the pedals were so small so he just
walked out baref to the bathroom and I
was in there and I was kind of whacking
it a little bit but it was kind of hot
knowing that I'm a a pilot you know you
were you were wait so I didn't really
blow I was just playing you know I was
really turned on but I was so you're in
so hold on you go into this simulat the
simulator who's the guy how come you
were in there with him no he was getting
out of it and showing me you had to
change the dials or change the the
program every time an employee I don't
know he was must be another student or
something using so then you went in the
cockpit it was it was a fake cockpit
it's like a little thing you walk into
yeah I know what you mean so you go in
the cockpit and then you close the door
yeah and I had it then you
with the instruments because I had to
make sure was set for what I needed for
takeoff and and you did that while
masturbating well I did a little bit
because he was really hot but that was
about it but he didn't really really
know which was good and then he came
back and did you take your dick out or
did you keep it in your pants it was
kind of in my pants I took it out a
little bit through my pants through my
zipper but then the zipper got caught I
was in so much pain that [__] hurt oh
my God you got a caught in a zipper on
that day too you know most of those
things have cameras in them dude don't
those all
yeah for
sure they all have cameras
bro so there we have we have kind of
[Music]
a
they don't show that I'm not good yeah
anyway so I iau it I buttoned it there
was some
personal that was my most improved golf
player because in
19991 before I graduated high school 92
I struggled a bit but I really loved
Golf and I thought I'd get a golf
scholarship because a really great sport
I still like golf to this day golf's a
great sport it's good for the brain and
everything too as well um so but I I
don't have my baseball tring anyway man
it's been a pleasure to catch up and um
it's been nice to hear from you and we
learned actually a lot today about and
thank you for showing me your [__] as
well that was nice of
you you're such a good I'm not scared
like I I I'm just know look when you're
an adult in spr you just don't give a
[__] and thank you for letting us tweet
it out too that was really cool thank
you I appreciate that I I don't care
what people think about it because I
know I like it I know many people liked
it but I think it's beautiful I have no
no quarms about it but I saying you're
right that guy went an idiot he didn't
know what the measurement was but I
never cared after that I just enjoyed
the moment okay that's all that matters
enjoying the moment yeah and um thank
you so much well I'm sure we'll talk
soon and I wish you the best and I hope
you find your twin flame out there MH
thank you I'm GNA try to get out there
one of these days to um to see if I can
um you know get out to LA because I
actually got a request to do a shoot in
LA but I really just I like Vegas Vegas
is
great all right thank you so much have a
great evening okay thanks a lot C man
man happy birthday happy birthday thank
you
so you can keep oh I was going to say
keep it up so that was that was actually
really Illuminating in terms of like
that everybody got to see his dick which
I think let me go pull that up on my
phone I just want to review it that was
wild that was awesome every time every
time he delivers um that was such a nice
uh new tidbit to learn though that uh he
lives with his mom and takes care of his
elderly mother and like we've always got
the sense that he's you know he's quirky
he's an OD you know he's a unique
individual but he seems like he's a good
guy at heart and that that kind of
confirms that for me that uh that he's
doing that for his mom really nice I had
a few Revelations about him today one
being that the man is on a severe dry
spell he hasn't had a partner since damn
March and the second one is that he
lives with his mom wow this is all huge
breaking Revelations about caman yeah
Mom I'm sorry so let's see this made my
day small PP crew well okay but you guys
see what I'm saying at least like when
when I saw this I felt like you
know betrayed frankly because I imagine
him having this huge [__] hog in his
fans I believe him I thought it possible
I do I thought it was possible seeing
that first photo but after he just did
this live I'm out I'm with you you
believe me yeah because I don't even I
think it's probably even below average
size and I don't say that I'm not I'm
I'm just speaking from a factual point
perspective I think you got a little bit
more in the tank I think you can squeeze
it out maybe an inch
more really shy to I have faith if
anybody can make magic happen I'm
certainly positive that it's C man you
know what I mean well he's definitely a
grower we know that no know that we've
seen his fled dick
too that's a micro that's not true
that's not cool no definitely not micro
I think it's probably about average it's
average for sure yeah
yeah about average yeah I'd average yeah
about average but you know I mean he's
just so serious about everything so you
believe that he has a 12 incher potenti
interesting I think that if he wants to
make it happen he can just like he says
just he it's just the will need
interesting this is pretty awesome
though that we got to tweet those out
yeah we got a new meme template too out
of uh him looking at his screen I sent a
screen cap in in Discord but seeing this
being shared already look at Alfredo he
he got groomed that was such an
interesting moment I I was like yeah I
was concerned oh my God Fluffy
Boy such a fluffy
boy I know it was you how white he is
it's crazy he he he went down like 10
Shades M was so dirty he was pretty
filthy yeah you're so white you're so
white
over so fluffy
[Music]
anyway I thought the [__] was wi that's
what I said to the
[Music]
groomer um well there it is you know
there it is nice to see it from staros
good guy yeah that was fun people be
bailing on our shows they're not they're
not used to the uh the three-hour long
bonanzas that we do here on the show can
you do yeah what can you do Nobody Does
it Like Us folks that's what I keep
saying yeah maybe there's a reason
nobody else doesn't like
us they hate us cuz they ain't
us that's the only reason as everybody
knows is true yeah who taught us that
the other day who was that that was um
Matt R oh Matt R right that's the only
reason anybody hates anybody they hate
us because they ain't us right
yeah well there it is
um how long we' been going 3 hours okay
so guys yeah go check out a special
support our boy stavos yeah did we tweet
out C man's website or did he send it to
you uh he has not emailed me yet I'll
email him right now yeah I want to
promote I want to reminder send me your
Twitter account so we can retweet you
give them a
plug and maybe after we can put like
also watch Fat Rascal on
Netflix yeah maybe no may not at the
same tweet yeah different tweets
yeah can we God cut something for Tik
Tok of staros talking [__] about Joe
Rogan don't do that to him I'm kidding
come on I I'll edit it very good I'll do
that I'm kidding uh you know I what he
was saying about Rogan's uh um uh comedy
club or whatever and how they they pay
the lowend uh comedian and everything
that actually is cool I I'll give Joe
some credit for that yeah it sounds cool
I
agree it's pretty
cool so okay stos he he put up a good
defense for Joe yeah and uh that's nice
you know different perspective I was I
was I was
receptive oh we didn't shout out the
steamies voting should I do that do it
right now it's been pinned in the the
chat all episode we'll we'll keep
promoting it throughout oh yeah oh yeah
so
guys the steamies is right around the
corner um it is next weekend my goodness
gracious and uh it's time to get your
votes
in we have
categories it's on pinned on our Twitter
but I think we're also putting it in the
chat right now is that right they call
them Dum it's been pinned in the chat
all episode uh I'm putting in the
description right now Twitter it's
everywhere yeah we've got 10,000 votes
already so oh
fantastic oh we've got the spiciest
drama worst National brain rot
discourse biggest cringe
moment worst apology best apology there
is only one nominee there I guess you
can write something in but I don't know
what you
know uh worst uh award show there's one
nominee I wonder who will
win most unhinged Creator this is a huge
category we had a lot of great entries
this year it's been a big year for
unhinged uh creators definitely you know
every year the big category changes
because like when we first started this
most dramatic Creator was like the the
the ultimate you know like best actor
type of thing but but I feel that you
know the drama is it's not what's
important this year actually I feel
that um the big categories are
probably I mean spiciest drama is good
that's a good category that's probably
the big one this
year string moment is I'm looking
forward to worst
apology um most unhinged Creator is a
massive massive category where are the
police Awards
lots of people doing illegal things
potentially this
year most dramatic Creator and again
this one is just kind of abstract you
know
um but it's yeah I mean it's just
basically on Vibes best influencer song
Worst kick platform moment shout out to
kick the new platform making an entry
here yeah absolutely doxer of the Year
big category lots of excitement worst
debater also new category based on this
year's uh podcast M biggest influencer
catastrophe lifetime lack of Achievement
Award interesting category I wonder who
will win that one biggest [__] award
that's a big one that I'm really um
that's a huge one I'm I'm curious who's
going to win that one
right um but um I'm excited it's coming
it's coming
fast 11 days we'll be live for
everybody as we always do it from our
Channel and it's going to be a ton of
fun GP coming at you oh let me read some
uh
donos next time we need stavi to teach
Ethan how to pick crabs my family lives
in stav's Ronnie
videos he is he a p is he a crabber uh
well I don't know what that's referring
to but the Ronnie videos I think are his
uh football videos which yeah I'm not
even into football and I watch all of
his football videos because they're
really [__] funny just for the [__]
talk he does massive amount he's a huge
uh Baltimore uh football guy CU that's
where he's from and uh he pretty much
every week puts out a video reacting to
the game and uh like I said I I don't
even watch you watch it and you're not
even you don't even it's just W his his
[__] talk game is just way too [__]
good interesting yeah
yeah um excuse me m mic said thank you
for the for the Dono appreciate that I'm
a performance driver and love to have C
man sit in on my vehicle during a track
dude what
if you know how there's like these
racetracks where you can go sit this is
what he's saying do crazy racetrack lubs
high speed and Sean jerk off at high
speeds or like burning out I've done
that one before we did that a video like
that in
Vegas so end like the Jay Leno video
jerk off while while crashing and
rolling I mean that could be fun I you
know take it to the next level
yeah um that's a good offer Mountain
mechanic how do you feel about him
finishing on your
feet for or against Aaron an says as a
former what is
f uh friends with benefits oh got it
I've been out of the game for too long
uhhuh a former friend with benefits of
mine is a grower he would go from about
3 in to over eight anything is possible
that's a taking favor of SE man yeah
okay I just I'm glad that everybody gets
to see what I saw everyone can draw
their own conclusions Aaron I'm curious
what Aaron says now because I I saw this
comment before the pictures were
released MH Aaron i' I'd love to if
you're still in chat
did your opinion
change oh yeah dbrand Mill said
uh uh rest in peace Ralph Cella who
was anyone that's um a Howard ster show
fan knows about Ralph was Howard's best
friend a stylist and he tragically died
uh yesterday or today really sad young
guy too it's in his 50s that one's been
uh hitting me hard
yeah it sucks it's really crazy 58
unexpected Ralph actually stayed with my
parents back in the
90s why um when my dad was owned his
Transportation excuse my voice um when
my dad owned his transportation business
he drove Howard when he was in LA and
Ralph needed a place to stay and my
parents couldn't get rid of him oh
that's
awesome oh that's so good yeah he was a
he was a good character a great
character and um very sad to hear the
news peace Ralph bir Weber said maybe
savy would have stayed around for a food
segment wouldn't you love a handmade
meal right now Dan or crew I would be so
grateful if you would scope out my
messages through Discord all
right I'm assuming it has something to
do with
food thank you no probably not just
unrelated
yeah all right I'm really curious Aaron
are you still in the chat because I
really want to know if your opinion
changed or
um you can leave a comment too I guess
I'll oh wait is that her no there's
another Aaron
okay uh it looks like they might not be
here anymore because I'm trying to tag
them in the chat usually pop up with the
account if they're here but so Ain if
you do get to this part uh not McVey I
see her in chat not McVey Aaron leave a
comment after you've seen his [__] and
let us know what you think we'll P it
yeah so today is um Wednesday we'll be
back on Friday we've got a great show
planned any sneak
peeks I'm always hesitant we we do have
uh somebody
that we've been wanting to talk to lined
up for a Callin on Friday but I've I've
learned from experience that every time
I say this it ends up not working out or
getting postponed or something so this
person is confirmed but I agree with you
I I feel like th this person is probably
someone that keeps their commitments I I
would agree think so probably but we'll
see okay so just tune in it's going to
be fun tune in and find out but somebody
that we've talked about on the show uh a
decent amount and uh you'll definitely
be interested to hear from this person
this isn't my first rodeo very good all
right thank you everybody oh eel pit
[__] Friday the uh oh that guest would
actually be pretty interested in I think
so I'll wait for that yeah yeah all
right everyone thank you so much for
watching thank you to the members thank
you to everyone really for watching
um and uh see you guys on
Friday next week is our last week of
shows you guys before the winter break
right right reminder that the live show
is the finale for the year so uh and
that's on a Saturday it's on a Sunday
Sunday it's on so are we not doing a
show on Friday in Li of the Sunday one I
guess probably not right uh plan on it
right as of right now the plan was to do
one but honestly I take the extra day
for prep for the live I'll take whatever
I can get I want to make sure that we're
we might have a sponsor obligation
though so we might have to do it anyways
I don't know but maybe we can shift it
around so I guess you get a bonus
episode next week yeah yeah well we'll
we'll discuss we'll see what we can do
oh soundbite Olympics that's coming up
next week I mean uh I I had that marked
for that Friday but oh well that's that
would be a a wonderful day then okay so
we'll do the sound bite Olympics the day
before our pen
ultimate episode final episode mhm so
next week's going to be a whole uh
morish Borg of fun it's gonna be a
bonanza yeah it sure is christalia
confirmed for Friday somebody said yeah
for
sure I love that c man says there's
people mistaking him for being a 16 oh
by the way no I don't believe that I got
Zach sick because he seems to be sick
with a different bug than me I got this
um I I was out last Friday cuz I was at
a
hospital um I think I gotten something
there yeah he's got he's got a fever
which uh I didn't have I just I just had
cough thing going
on you could test for covid uh three
times I'm negative that's good just
regular old flu my voice is just like
[__] gone man that's S I hate that
okay everybody have a fantastic
wonderful uh evening and tomorrow and
we'll be back on Friday
lost in the music your heart will be
mine all I
need is look your
eyes bees in
space